this is your one minute notice this
meeting will start in one minute
in the football game okay good morning
everyone
if you could all take your seats please
Welcome to the
Monday January 30th meeting of the
science technology and energy committee
and we will begin this morning by all
rising and joining representative Munns
as he joins us in the pledge or leads us
in the Pledge of Allegiance
thank you representative munz we are
here today to hear
five bills
in public hearing
this morning we will hear house bills
175 176 and 208.
after a lunch break we will come back to
hear house bills 443 and house bill 630.
and then at four o'clock this afternoon
we'll be having an executive session at
which time we will
adjudicate on House Bill 418 house bill
for 576 and house bill 92.
before we get started I'll remind
everyone in attendance here today that
if you would like to speak on any of
these bills I need a pink card filled
out and delivered
to uh the head of the
or to the clerk by as soon as possible
actually uh as soon as you know you're
going to speak
I want to point out that
there are quite a few members of the
committee who are absent today
like the Cincinnati Bengals and the San
Francisco 49ers yesterday it was not a
good weekend for some members of St e
yeah
representative Christian apparently had
a tussle with some ice and uh broke her
ankle so she's not here today
representative lewicki is in the
hospital for reasons unknown
uh so
as a result you'll see a few empty spots
around the table today so I I hope
you'll keep our missing numbers and your
thoughts and prayers as we go forward
today
and with that we can begin our activity
for today and so I will open the public
hearing on House Bill 175 relative to
the state's energy consumption reduction
goal and I will call to the
chair the prime sponsor of that bill
representative Michael Harrington
representative Harrington
yeah good morning and let's enjoy the
warmth I guess while we have it because
it's supposed to get really cold later
in the week maybe it'll actually be
comfortable in this building finally
um this is a kind of a no-brainer it's
it just changes the word reduce fossil
fuel consumption to reduce greenhouse
gas emissions which is more encompassing
it covers anything that has greenhouse
gas implications rather than just fossil
fuels it was put up by the department
requested by the department of energy a
couple of years ago I don't remember how
it got lost on the shuffle but somehow
it did must have been in the covid
shuffle or whatever but Dave I've spoken
with Chris Elms again on it they're
still they're in support of it uh they
think it's a it makes more sense to have
greenhouse gas emissions as the goal to
reduce rather than just fossil fuels and
there's nothing more complicated to it
than that so if anyone has questions
feel free to ask
thank you that was uh short and sweet
representative Thomas has a question
Doug Thomas that is thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question so uh
perhaps I missed a follow-up but uh uh
my understanding is I remember because I
was here then that um in the community
report at the time uh the a bill similar
to this was was introduced uh through
here and I believe it was passed and it
hit the house uh and in the committee
report in the calendar I stated that
that that we were going to itl that bill
because the change had already been made
so I'm trying to
understand if that was true then why are
we resubmitting the bill now were we
Incorrect and saying the the change had
been made because we were told at the
time that the change by the Des people
that the change had been made so I'm
confused I well I I will join you in
your confusion all I can tell you is
when you look up the law it says fossil
fuel as it's shown on the bill and it
wasn't changed to greenhouse gas
emissions and so I didn't even know who
brought it to my attention I think it
was someone from Des I looked at it and
said okay I'll put it back in and I just
I say it was I checked with Chris Elms
over the weekend he was supposed to have
the Griff here today but he's not in for
whatever reason maybe he's hopefully
he's not in the hospital like all these
other people
um uh but they were going to say they
support the change because it's just
it's just kind of Common Sense
foreign
representative munz has a question
yeah I I think uh thank you Mr chairman
and thank you representative for
introducing the bill I I just wanted to
uh to follow up on representative
um
representative Thomas's um question
that was in I think the 2021 session in
the 2020 session the same bill was
introduced and it was the same situation
where it was determined that the that
the bill was not needed so I guess I'm I
joined with representative Thomas and
just trying to understand why why why we
need to do this well let me do this so
we don't waste a lot of time I will
research this and see if it's still
needed the Des the department of energy
people told me they wanted it I'll get
back with them I'll recheck the law and
I'll send out something to the committee
so we don't have to waste any more time
on deciding whether it's needed or not
if it's not needed I'll withdraw the
bill
thank you
well we do have a
Mr Fitzgerald from Des who has offered
to testify on this bill he may be able
to clarify this situation for us so if
there are no further questions for
representative Harrington I'll I'd like
to call on um well first I'd remind
representative Harrington to fill out a
pin card and then I will all I have to
do as a sponsor yes even I sponsor you
have to submit a pink card for the
official record
um that representative Bernardi is our
well it's going to be easy because now I
know how much time I spend to you so I
can fill that out accurately for once
okay
and Mike Fitz go well if you can explain
it feel free and then I will call on
Mike Fitzgerald from New Hampshire Des
e good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee
Michael Fitzgerald I'm the assistant
director of the air Resources Division
at the Department of Environmental
Services
prior to the creation of the Department
of Energy Des
was significantly involved in energy
tracking for state and we were
significantly involved in the uh setting
these goals in the executive order that
followed
but intimately involved in the
legislation that that established these
goals back in 2010 one of the reasons
that the term fossil fuel use was
adopted was because it was somewhat more
amenable to State many state agencies
who greenhouse gases tracking and so on
didn't make a lot of uh didn't uh you
know resonate and so we we just decided
um
the interest here was in energy
management in reducing energy costs and
and reducing energy usage in state
government and so uh in 2010 this goal
was in Wisconsin statute and then
re-uh affirmed uh by by a later
Governor's executive order
um
so Des uh and the since the Inception of
this goal the state has saved via report
the department of administrative
Services who could not be here today was
ranta Mackey from the from Das would be
happy to respond to questions or provide
additional information but based on
their report of State Energy savings
with that they track
um up through last year the state has
received approximately 50 million
dollars in Energy savings as a result of
of energy management energy reductions
that have been implemented since this
executive order
uh our concern with this bill is that uh
if you change to greenhouse gas
emissions
the goal will have already been met
um and that the goal of 25 percent
um and that's partially due to the fact
that the state changed over from
um uh very different forms of energy
from significant use of oil to natural
natural gas in several places also wood
energy has been has been used and all of
that has resulted in significant
greenhouse gas emission reductions
um so it's it's not
a direct correlation between uh
fossil fuel usage and greenhouse gas
emission reductions
the Chris skogland
who is here today and uh is with clean
energy New Hampshire was part of my
staff up until last year and he worked
intimately on this so he could I believe
he intends on testifying he can provide
you with some uh some greater detail and
information as to as to the uh to the
numbers but
um I I think that our belief is that if
this were to change we're not we don't
object to the change to greenhouse gas
emissions but the goal would need to be
adjusted to account for those greenhouse
gas emission reductions that have
already occurred so in in other words
um the I believe the number is somewhere
in the 30 to 40 percent range that we've
already achieved so the 25 percent
that's in here now we believe was should
be adjusted to account for greenhouse
gases rather than fossil fuels we don't
have any concern with the change of the
terminology just the fact that if that's
done the goal will have already been
achieved so it will be of no value going
forward in incenting energy state
agencies to continue to reduce energy
use and to save costs for State of New
Hampshire and the citizens of the State
of New Hampshire
so with that uh
it was my testimony and I'm happy to try
to address questions again Mr skoglund
probably has more intimate knowledge and
detail than myself but we and again Das
would be available to try to answer
questions also
thank you for for your testimony
representative Doug Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question uh on
unfortunately the the question at hand
is not the merits of this bill right now
it's the question is do are are you
aware If the previous Bill uh that was
approved by the house a couple of years
ago did that ever get signed by the
governor and if so why it did not wind
up in the rsas because I don't feel we
can move forward on this bill until we
answer that question
I I do not believe that occurred again
Mr skoglund might be able to address
that a little bit more I do know that
this bill was brought forward last year
as representative Harrington mentioned
he and I discussed it briefly
um and he had he indicated as he had
before that had been a request of staff
from the
um
precursor to the Department of energy
the office of strategic initiatives and
uh
um we I raised the same same issues with
him at that time and then he
subsequently withdrew it last year but I
could not speak to the prior year but I
don't I believe the statute is still the
same I don't believe the statute has
been changed I'm not sure of the history
of of the bill but we could I could
certainly look that up and and get back
to you on it
thank you please do
representative Summers asked a question
thank you Mr chairman just a quick
question for clarification you had
stated there that greenhouse gases were
lowered due to uh the use of natural gas
and natural gas is a fossil fuel correct
absolutely
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
coming back to the committee
um I I believe in the report that you
were referencing where you mentioned the
50 million dollar reduction it stated
that the reduction in fossil fuels since
2005 has been about 17 percent
um and you also mentioned that the
reduction in greenhouse gases is about
30 to 40. so does that suggest that
there is like a two to one relationship
between the percentage reduction in in
greenhouse gas emissions and the
percentage reduction of fossil fuels
well I wouldn't make that in general but
certainly in some specific fuels for
instance natural gas and oil and it's
basically it has to do with the btu
content of the uh of the fuel so that
you may you you burn less natural gas
to get the same amount of energy uh so
and and but different fuels have
different values so I wouldn't say
that's it's specifically two to one but
um basically uh as a result of the fuel
switching that has been done now that
ratio would have would certainly appear
to be
fairly accurate follow-up
follow-up so if that's the case then if
we wanted to switch over to the gas
greenhouse gas emissions standard the
standard should be something closer to
40 or 50 50 something I mean that would
need to be discussed and certainly our
our department and uh Das and doe can
you know engage we'd be willing to
engage on that
um but uh
you know and obviously the governor's
office would need to be involved in
making
you know deciding what our agencies
would recommend as a uh an appropriate
goal
thank you
representative McWilliams has a question
uh thank you chair Bose and thank you Mr
Fitzgerald for your testimony
I I just want to understand if we were
to amend this bill because it sounds
like there's some good stuff in it
um
we're looking at a 2005 Baseline which
was you know 18 years ago
would it be possible to update the
Baseline if we were to amend this bill
do we have another year that we use as a
baseline say 2015 or is there a number
that the department typically looks to
it's been a while
yeah
um as as I mentioned I think this goal
was established in 2010 and so the 22
2005 Baseline but we could certainly
um that that's certainly something that
the three agencies would want to look at
and and make a determination as to what
an appropriate Baseline would would be
thank you
representative Nutter has a question
thank you I'm not sure how to word this
correctly
um
after all is said and done with all the
mandates and not allowing these reliable
sources of fuel what is the percentage
um for in the air quality
like it's point zero zero something
percent
I'm not sure if I what what do you mean
when you say percentage in air quality
what do you mean well I've seen it up on
a screen I was at a conference and they
were talking about New Hampshire
follow-up Mr chairman I'm sorry yes
um that it was up on the screen they
were talking about New Hampshire and
with all the mandates and the greenhouse
gas emission emissions and um doing away
with fossil fuels and the the air
quality was better by
0.00 something percent is that which you
have
air quality is measured and by a number
of parameters
um uh if if you're referring to
greenhouse gases that would be a carbon
dioxide which is measured in on the
order of parts per million in the
atmosphere and it's a global pollutant
but there's also air quality is measured
by particulate matter which that's
particulate matter is significantly
um connected to to fossil fuel use
burning combustion of fossil fuels
results in significant amounts of
particulate matter
um and so I I would need to certainly
get back to you in terms of any any of
those specific parameters I can't think
think certainly of an overall air
quality number that would be
that that might comport with what you're
referencing I I'd need to see what
information you're you're referencing
representative Bernardi has a question
more of a point of order uh Mr chair uh
this bill deals with changing of
language from fossil fuel to greenhouse
gas
it may or may not be relevant it seems
like we've diverted to amending the bill
to talk about changing goals I don't
think that's the subject of the bill
that's not an amendment that's on the
floor I think we need to get answer the
question of is this necessary or not and
maybe our assistant can help us with
whether or not it has actually been
docketed in the rsas
thank you representative Noel has a
question
thank you Mr chair uh I'm a little
confused about the units of measure for
fossil fuel consumption versus
greenhouse gas emissions are those on a
weight basis or are those they're on a
uh actually in the statute this is on a
per square foot of uh you know this is
referencing state buildings since you
know this this building included so it's
energy energy use
um I'm not sure whether the numbers in
BTUs or in pounds or or whatever but
it's but it's in on a per square foot
basis
um uh so it's it's not
um you know overall it's it's energy use
intensity
follow up thank you Mr chair
so effectively the the two
the two uh
resources would be measured in the same
way
following the standard if I understand
you correctly yes it would be measured
on a per square foot usage and that's
how the department of administrative
Services uh tracks energy usage in the
state now uh towards achieving the goal
that's currently in statute
thank you
okay seeing no further questions foreign
we clearly understand that there's not
an amendment before the here I my point
was simply that the goal is not is not
consistent with the unit change so we
would want we as an agency we we think
that's something that should be
considered
so even though there is not an amendment
before us you would like to see one that
that's that's our
okay great feeling message received
thank you
uh representative Thomas has decided he
has another question uh actually uh this
is uh another uh point of order for the
chair uh could you please advise uh
future speakers that we're talking about
the subject of this bill at hand
uh and please uh if they could present
their discussions as to this particular
Bill matter
will do okay seeing no further questions
of Mr Fitzgerald I'd like to thank you
for being here this morning and I'd like
to call next to the stand Chris skogland
representing clean energy New Hampshire
formerly of the Department of
Environmental Services welcome Chris
foreign
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee
as has been mentioned I'm Chris goglin
I'm the director of energy transition
with clean energy New Hampshire
formerly I was with the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services for
14 years 10 years of which was spent
maintaining a database on behalf of the
Department of administrative services
that dealt with this issue just a little
bit of History to answer some of the
questions I've heard today this change
was first proposed in House Bill 1261
during in 2020 which due to the pandemic
I believe was set aside but was not
enrolled in any of the Omnibus bills so
that bill did not ultimately pass in
2021 in HB 399 it was introduced again
but I believe it was then withdrawn some
of the challenge has been uh
over the past several years with the
creation of the change of staff at the
office then office of strategic
initiatives and the creation of the
Department of energy kind of the history
of the bills as they've moved through
has been lost and so we've discussed
this
um a few times and I think
that may be where some of the confusion
stands in terms of its existence and
need but I would Echo having contributed
to some of the analysis for the last two
rounds Mr Fitzgerald's point that we
have met the goal
um
and that there may need to be a point of
reconsidering whether to change the
Baseline change the end Year from 2025
to 2020 I mean 2030
um
but what I would note is that the
existing goal has been instrumental in
driving New Hampshire's the state of New
Hampshire's energy cost savings we've
avoided almost 48 million dollars as of
the end of fiscal year 2021 I believe uh
the new energy manager with the state is
calculating and is due to release a
report for fiscal year 2022 shortly
um but one of the reasons why we chose
fossil fuels around the time frame of
2010 was we had just come out of the
2008-2009 energy price spikes and I was
at that time it was felt that fossil
fuels were an excellent proxy for uh
fuels that uh were influenced by a
global market but also did impact a
broad range of environmental
considerations so the 48 million dollars
um
does reflect price changes over time but
it also and the insulation we've
provided
and I'll pause there if there are any
other questions I am happy to answer
them oh I will no uh the previous the
target is measured on a kbtu per square
foot basis when we're looking at energy
and the fossil fuels would most likely
be in a pounds per square foot basis
or tons per square foot basis one of the
reasons why a per square foot basis was
chosen though is to reflect the fact
that the state might
open new facilities and that we didn't
want to ding the state by if the square
footage expands we didn't want to have
an absolute energy reduction goal or an
absolute fossil fuel reduction goal that
we would just be looking at each
building
on a building by building basis so it
was to reflect that the state's building
square footage might go up or down
a little bit of nuance there
representative Doug Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question I'll I'll ask you
the same question and hopefully I hope I
can get either a two or three letter
answer yes or no
since this bill in 2021 did hit the
calendar uh with my recommendation that
I'd be itl'd I'm assuming it went before
the house for a vote which maybe maybe
what was itl
did HB 399
get voted on and was the result itl at
the time or was it OTP yeah that's the
main Crux of this bill
trying to be brief it's my recollection
and it's the reflection of the docket
that it was and in fact uh italt
thank you
representative uh McWilliams has a
question
thank you chair Bose and thank you Mr
skobin for your testimony
I just want to understand here the the
piece you talked about with increasing
square footage for State offices
um can you explain to me how that's
different between fossil fuel
consumption and greenhouse gas emissions
if we decide to put in a new facility
that say no 100 000 square feet
the the consideration would not change
in that the language of the bill as
written keeps the green keeps the
intensity language still there so it's
greenhouse gas intensity the way that
when I was part of the state and now
would interpret that is it's a
pounds or tons of CO2 or other
greenhouse gases that are emitted per
square foot of building space so if we
added a new building
the goal would be to achieve that same
reduction below whatever Baseline you're
set in this case it's 2005. and the 2005
year was set because that was a
executive order that had been issued
that established that Baseline back in
2005.
thank you
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chairman thank you thank you for
coming in
um isn't there a existing order
executive order on file currently that
raised the uh Target from 25 percent by
2025 to 40 percent and if so wouldn't
that suggest that if we switched over to
greenhouse gases that
we would want to have a number that's a
percentage that's significantly higher
than so they're talking about oh sorry
uh and thank you for the question and
also thank you to others for your
questions uh there was an executive
order issued in 2016 executive order
2000 or 2016-03 and I believe that that
uh
increase the goal
and in my mind I want to say it went to
50 but I also think that the years that
it went out also was extended and that
was to reflect that we had seen a great
deal of uh success
in achieving our goal
follow-up to just for the record I'm
looking at at the at the report that
references this and it's a states that
the executive order uh raised the goal
up to 40 by 2025 and 50 by 2030.
that is my recollection thank you thank
you
okay seeing no further questions for Mr
skogland I want to thank you for being
here this afternoon and or this morning
and talking to us
and uh with that I have no more pink
cards for this bill so I am going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
175.
we will be hearing House Bill 176 at 10
A.M
representative closure will now let us
know the outcome of any
blue sheet activity
uh thank you Mr chair
House Bill 175
there was zero in favor of it
40 against
thank you
we appreciate that
so we won't start our next public
hearing until 10 a.m so that gives us
some time
and so I'm going to ask representative
Bernardi
to continue our
organization day orientation about the
activities of the committee
by describing
what will happen in an executive session
now this topic is relevant because at
four o'clock this afternoon the
committee will be having its first
executive session so representative
Bernardi will walk you through what will
happen in an executive session and then
we can ask and answer any questions that
may arise so representative Bernardi
thank you Mr chair uh this discussion of
executive session responsibilities flows
from house rules 103 and 104.
so preliminary requirements and
scheduling the chairman is responsible
for scheduling specific bills for
executive session with the committee
assessed assistant since time management
is very essential uh
um it's important to uh to schedule
these bills so that they particularly so
that we can meet calendar timelines
um with respect to the rest of House
business
a quorum is required in the committee
and the Quorum is not present uh and a
vote is critical there's a deadline or
something like that uh you are advised
to please contact the speaker's office
particularly if you're not if you know
you can't be here for some reason a
substitute can be
acquired and and be there in your place
so proceedings and motions opening the
session chairman opens an executive
session no vote is required to open that
session
discussion
chairman should only recognize committee
members promotions and discussion
members of the public may be recognized
at the chair's discretion for
informational purposes
motions
the chairman should ask for a motion he
may not make it himself
if in order for a discussion to begin on
a bill an emotion must be seconded or
the bill is withdrawn
there are
the Motions that can be made are ought
to pass
ought to pass with Amendment and
expedient to legislate retain if it's
the first year of a biennium and refer
to interim study in the second year only
the subcommittee chairman if there was
one will be recognized to make that
first motion if the bill was sent to a
subcommittee
preliminary discussion on a bill is
appropriate if the members are not ready
to vote or then there's a need for
additional information
tabling of a bill is not allowed
in a committee executive session
so the voting process first is putting
the question chair will say are you
ready to vote the motion is
and then Define what that motion is
you must be present in order to vote you
may only vote on a motion if you were
present when the question was actually
put
so if you happen to be outside going to
the restroom and came back and you you
may not come in and vote
conflicts if a member is present and
must vote on a motion unless he is filed
he or she has filed the form with the
clerk declaring the member's intention
not to vote for some conflict
amendments
amendments must be voted on individually
and but they may not be uh
amendments may have to be voted on
individually but if there are multiple
amendments uh they must be Consolidated
into one final Amendment uh to the uh to
the bill under question
members offering amendments should have
copies prior to the start of the
executive session
and amendments are identified by their
amendment number provided by OLS office
of legislative services
amendments may be adopted by Voice vote
or show of hands or roll call vote this
is the Chairman's discretion
roll call vote is required for in all
committee final recommendations house
rule 107.
changing of one's vote a member may
change his or her vote before the final
vote is announced
consent calendar
the chairman customarily asked the
committee if there's any objection to
placing a bill on the consent calendar
assuming there seems to be unanimity or
only one or two uh uh contrary votes if
there is no objection the bill may be
placed on the consent calendar
if there's any bills with more than two
navotes the custom is to place it on the
regular calendar
no bills with fiscal impact or an or any
appropriation may be placed on the
consent calendar house rule 51
reconsideration a motion for
reconsideration is appropriate and does
not require a member making the motion
to have voted on the prevailing side
excuse me I have violated the rules here
and reconsideration motion is only in
order when the committee ha still has
possession of the bill so if the bill
has left the committee no further
reconsiderations is available
foreign
okay thank you for that excellent
summary representative Bernardi are
there any questions representative munz
appears to have a question yes thanks Mr
chair
um
subcommittees uh can members request
that there be a subcommittee how does
that work
yes a member can request it although the
chair makes the final decision about
whether to form a subcommittee but it
can be requested follow-up and when
would be the appropriate time to ask for
that would that be
um
after the motion has been made in the
executive committee during the hearing
no the motion to form a subcommittee
should happen during the course of the
public hearing on a bill
executive session is way too late we
can't form a subcommittee if you're
already an executive session because
you're going to vote on them on the bill
so you need to form a subcommittee early
in the process Sometimes some committees
even form subcommittees before they hear
a bill in public hearing for example the
Commerce Committee has four standing
subcommittees
and they assign every bill that gets
assigned to the committee to a
subcommittee
and those subcommittees take charge of
the public hearing process on the bill
doing research on the bill and they
ultimately make a recommendation on the
final bill to the full committee
That's the Way Commerce organizes
themselves
we haven't done that in this committee
we've talked about it but have decided
that the subject matter of our committee
is such that it would be hard to to come
up with three or four standing
committees
um
to which to refer bills so what we do
instead is we decide as we go through
the public hearing process does this
look like a bill that needs a
subcommittee and if it is then we form
one for example last year we had a bill
on
5G
uh matters and whether
um
there was a public health
effect
from the output of of these radio
transmitters and it was a complicated
subject in fact there had been a study
Commission
the previous year that had issued a
thousand page report on this subject so
we did form a study committee to
ascertain just how to proceed with that
bill
and we probably will will do something
similar this year if we have time
is the other critical factor in forming
a subcommittee
uh a subcommittee requires a small group
a subset of this committee to get
together on a separate day and time to
discuss what to do with the bill so
if our timelines are really tight it
might be difficult to schedule a
subcommittee session for a particular
bill but we can try and we'll we'll
discuss that amongst ourselves as the
need arises
thank you okay representative Corman has
a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Bernardi for explaining
to us how the process works uh
representative Bernardi said that the
chair solicits a motion can emotion be
made uh without the chair soliciting
no
thank you
yeah representative and I've apologized
Jack
representative Jack has a question thank
you Mr chairman I wonder if
representative Bernardi would touch on
the process after the vote is taken how
do we get the committee report who
writes it how long do you have how do we
get a Minority Report that sort of thing
the the chairman uh normally assigns or
asks who is going to write the minority
and majority report
um if the amendment is proposed by or I
mean the bills proposed by someone in
the in the committee they're gonna
they're gonna end up writing that at
least one of those reports and I'll let
the chairman add to that yeah so
typically the person who makes the
motion that prevails writes that report
it could either be a majority report or
it could be a Minority Report or it
could be a report for the whole
committee
if the vote on the bill doesn't
necessarily require a Minority Report
then the report reflects the will of the
entire committee
so for example if we vote on a bill and
it's 20 to nothing in favor of the bill
we don't need a Minority Report
the majority of the committee has
decided
what
the fate of the bill is and that becomes
the committee report
because majority and minority members
have contributed to that decision does
that answer your question
yeah I actually knew that I just this
was for the benefit of anyone who's new
to this process oh okay great
representative Thomas would like to add
to that yes thank you and uh and I'm
sure and the chair would probably
mentioned this later on any committee
report that is written majority or
minority
must reflect accurately uh any points
that were brought out during the public
hearing or the executive session
um we've been advised the past there
have been some reports not from this
group because we have a good group here
but there are other committees that
sometimes have reports that actually are
completely different than what was
discussed during public hearing and so
it's up to the chair to decide to accept
or ask for amendments or changes to any
committee report
thank you representative Thomas to
expand on that a little bit all
committee reports come to me as chairman
and I evaluate those committee reports
and if they're not satisfactory in some
way I will ask the member who wrote the
report to make some changes if if
necessary
once I approve the report then it will
go into the calendar
representative Nutter has a question
yeah can the clerk's office
rewrite or edit
um we don't call them blurbs anymore my
majority reports are minority reports
the clerk and the speaker review all
minority and majority reports and they
can request changes from the committee
they're not allowed to make those
changes on their own
but they can request that we make them
and they can refuse essentially to
accept the report until those changes
are made
additional questions representative
McWilliams has one
thank you chair Bose what is the
deadline for submitting to you to review
for these reports post exec session
tough question
the ideal is to have a committee report
ready to go when you make a motion in
executive session
so that you can hand it to me before the
Executive before we leave that that day
that is the ideal
frequently
it's not possible to do that because the
motion made in committee ends up being a
little different than what
one might have anticipated so I
typically give people until noon the
next day to complete and and forward to
me their committee report
representative partial has a question
yes thank you chair most
um could you walk me through a little
bit of the process of amending a bill
during executive committee I'm forcing
the situation where Amendment may have
an impact on whether or not the bill
needs a subcommittee
which will not be possible I understand
okay I'll try to answer that
so the process during executive
committee
when you know you want to make an
amendment to a bill would be like this
you let me know ahead of time so that I
can recognize you for emotion and your
emotion will be
Mr chairman I move
ought to pass with Amendment and offer
amendment number XXX
that would be the motion
we would then take up the amendment and
if we pass the amendment then
the
the motion of ought to pass as amended
would be next to be adopted
actually I think I did that slightly
wrong what what the motion would be
would be
I move ought to pass and offer Amendment
xxxx
and then if the amendment passes then
the motion is ought to pass as amended
now in the case of multiple amendments
we've been advised that we have to
somehow
consolidate those amendments and that
process could be a little bit messy
and time consuming so we'll have to be
very very careful about how we go about
trying to
amend a bill more than once in committee
you can run up against the problem where
one Amendment might supersede another
and erase some of the
things you were trying to do in your
first amendment so it it can be
complicated and and you have to approach
that subject with care
representative merner has a comment yes
thank you Mr getting back to talking
about subcommittees on the first year I
remember here I think three or four
terms ago we retained almost 11 bills
and that's where we had a lot of
subcommittees because we saw bills that
needed a little more work so that
alleviates the deadline especially on
the first year legislation
so you can probably illuminate that a
little bit
thank you that's a good piece of
institution institutional knowledge that
you're passing along there we do
typically form subcommittees when we
retain bills because the purpose of
retaining a bill is to study it further
so
subcommittees are the best way to do
that representative Thomas sure
um I um if we don't know the answer
perhaps we can contact the clerk on this
during
a vote for an amendment during exact
session if the vote is a tie
is that does that mean the amendment
fails
yes
representative McWilliams
I just want to
suss a little bit more about how we do
amendments on this committee I have
presented bills to other committees
um where there was just a very small
Amendment say changing the date that the
bill would take effect and so at the
time that I presented the bill I also
presented the amendment because it was
such a small thing and so we did have a
situation last week on Tuesday's Bill
hearing date where we said we're not
hearing amendments at the time that we
hear the bill which leaves me in this
weird conundrum where well if we can't
hear an amendment and that might
potentially cause a subcommittee to want
to get together and do something how is
this committee going to handle that
so I'm just following advice given to me
by the house clerk Paul Smith who told
us that amendments cannot be considered
during public hearing only during an
executive session
and as I explained
during the public hearing where that
situation came up it's okay to talk in
general terms about the about the change
you want to make in an amendment
but the committee is not going to
consider the language of the amendment
during the public hearing
and that's advice I got directly from
the clerk who is an expert on Mason's
rules of procedure and that's the way we
we've been told to do it
okay
representative Jack has a question yeah
thank you uh someone who is not on the
committee can draft an amendment for the
committee's consideration but when the
executive session happens someone on the
committee must move the amendment
for it to be considered unless it was
the senator who drafted the amendment
and then you have to get a redraft with
an H number
good excellent point
excellent point
okay I'll tell you what let's take a six
minute uh recess at this point so we can
um
take care of personal business and then
we will resume our activity at 10
o'clock by hearing house bill
176. so we are in recess for six minutes
foreign
okay let's get started everyone I'd like
to open the public hearing on House Bill
176. I will remind anyone who wants to
speak on this legislation
to
hand me a pink card
sooner rather than later
including the prime sponsor
of the speaker of the bill who is
representative Michael Harrington
and so representative Harrington as soon
as you're ready you can present house
bill 176.
relative to the rules of the site
evaluation committee
this bill's come up in the past let me
start with saying that and I think the
last time it was sort of Lost in the
covet Haze with the justification being
that since there was no new energy
projects uh scheduled in New Hampshire
that there was no need to um to have
this built now what the bill does it
create
corrects what I think is a major mistake
by the site evaluation committee because
they way overstepped their Authority
there was a bill passed a few years ago
basically in response to the Antrim win
project which specified a number of new
legislative mandated requirements for
win projects only
and yet the site evaluation committee
and their Infinite Wisdom decided to
expand that to all energy projects so
for example you have an emergency
evacuation plan for a transmission line
well last I checked no one's living in a
transmission line so there's a lot of
unnecessary rules it sends a message
twofold one it says the Departments are
in charge of the state not the
legislature and it also sends a message
to everybody don't come to New Hampshire
because we're going to make life as
difficult as possible for you if you
want to build any energy projects now
it's we can debate all day what type of
energy project we should make but the
fact is we are going to have more energy
projects in the state for the simple
reason if we're going to electric cars
and electric heat and all these other
lofty goals we're going to need more
electricity in order to do that
especially if we plan on closing down
the fossil fuel facilities so more
electricity means more projects means
more transmission lines if we're going
to go with offshore wind well that's
really good but the electricity has to
go someplace leaving it out in the ocean
isn't powering a damn thing it's going
to come on land and that land requires
new transmission lines which will be
subject to all sorts of rules that the
legislature never required it to be done
this is a simple matter of housekeeping
telling the site evaluation committee
you overstepped your Authority you don't
have the legislative approval to do that
so change your rules and make them match
the law it's that simple it doesn't it
doesn't it shouldn't be a Democrat a
republican conservative liberal fossil
fuel no fossil fuel it's just telling a
state agency obey the law because you
don't have the authority to make it and
I'll take any questions anyone has
thank you representative Harrington
could you go through each of the
specific rule changes that you would
like to see the site evaluation
committee be instructed to change well I
suppose I could if we had half a day to
spend on this Mr chairman but the uh
fact is that there's a whole lengthy
list of them and the easiest way to do
that is to look at the bill that the the
legislation that was passed and compare
it to the rules which I'm not uh
prepared to do today it's a simple
matter of saying where the rule exceeds
the authority granted by the legislation
it needs to be changed to match it and
that's that's what the bill does it
simply says go change your rules to
match the legislation take the authority
that was granted to you make sure you
implement the law it was written but you
don't expand it to other things that it
wasn't applied to in the legislation
okay any further questions for
representative Harrington representative
McWilliams as a question no
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chairman and um thank you
representative for introducing this bill
as well
um for the record I mean this this a
similar bill was introduced twice
um once in 2022 and once in 2017 and it
was uh in both cases it was determined
that it was not necessary
um but can you you you talked you you
mentioned that the
site evaluation committee has exceeded
its legislative Authority
who has determined that they have
exceeded their legislative Authority
well for one I have and for a second
anybody that can read Because if you
look at the rules and you compare it to
the law the rule change was a direct
result of a law passed in response to
the Antrim win project because people
wanted uh I mean and to some extent it
was necessary because there was not a
lot of requirements in there and for
example
um I I say this because I've been on
seven eight nine side evaluation
committees in the past
um I think I'm the only one in the house
who's ever served on one but um
they had a lot of holes in there for
example there was no requirement for
decommissioning of wind projects so they
didn't have to have no statutory
requirement to say that you had to have
uh finances put aside so that at the end
of your usable life with whoever it is
25 years or 30 years that there would be
fine money there so you wouldn't just
leave this eyesore of an old windmill or
hundreds of old windmills sitting on the
top of a hill someplace
um so there was reasons for the law and
the law specified certain things
specific to win plans and when
facilities only And yet when the rule
was written uh it was applied to
everybody I wasn't in the legislature at
the time this was after I left the
commission and uh before I got back into
the house and I did contact gel car on
it and was basically told that
I won't use the exact language I was
told but let's just say this is so
screwed up no one knows what the hell it
means anyways so we're passing it
and uh that's what happened and it
became it became a rule but um if you if
you if you look at the the law and you
look at the rules you'll you clearly see
that what was applied exclusively to
wind and I referenced the statute here
uh was applied in the rules to all types
of energy projects which was a gross
over reach by the site evaluation
committee rules people
you need a follow-up
thank you okay thank you
representative Harrington
RSA 541a the administrative procedures
act specifies that
a state agency cannot create rules
for which it is has not received
legislative Authority
what is the procedure under RSA 541a for
dealing with the situation which you
describe namely that rules were written
without legislative Authority
uh Mr chairman thank you for the
question but I have to be honest with
you I don't know I know that I had this
bill put in twice now and I also was
involved in the rulemaking process I
submitted comments and like I say I went
to gel car over it and got nowhere so I
just think it's time that we make sure
that the uh the law is reflected in the
rules and the rules reflect the law and
not something else I I off the top of my
head I don't know what that process is
okay thank you
any further questions for representative
Harrington
seeing none thank you for introducing
this bill whoops representative Wendy
Thomas had a last minute question yes
thank you Mr chair
um
would this bill
um and I'm looking at uh line
um 14 on would this bill eliminate
emergency response plans for all energy
facilities is is that what this is
implying it would make the rules reflect
what's in the law and if we want to put
on additional requirements let's just
say I don't know for a solar facility uh
then we should put those in the law and
not uh say well we'll let the site
evaluation committee make them up and
put them in there that's the whole point
of this I think you know on a bigger
issue people have to understand if you
look at this from a broader ratio New
Hampshire and New England have a very
bad reputation for investing anything in
energy whether you're in favor of more
against them really doesn't make any
difference but we saw what a billion
dollars go into Northern Pass and was
wasted we've seen hundreds of millions
of dollars in the project up in Maine
for the transmission which got all the
apartments and then was overturned by a
referendum petition and now is hung up
in the courts we saw Antrim wind which
is you know is a name plate of think 28
megawatts so effectively it's about you
know producing about 12 megawatts per
hour on uh on average and that took I
think six years before they were able to
get approval so anything that we do if
someone comes in and looks and says wow
this state is allowing their uh
administrators to create law that makes
it more cumbersome and more burdensome
on energy projects they're going to say
nah I'll invest in Oklahoma
because they just I'm not going to come
here we have a we have a market-based
system here where it's Merchant plans
and we're sending a big loud message to
them we don't want you so all this is
again is an attempt to say the laws are
written by the legislature and not by
the agency and if there's a good reason
for putting in some particular
requirement that was only applied to win
to other facilities then someone should
bring forth a bill that does that
representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh one quick question I'm
aware that there has been studies and I
believe a bill perhaps uh coming forward
to reorganize the SEC I'm just wondering
if you are aware if that procedures
would contain any language in there that
would reflect what this bill does I I
know there's a one for substantial
reorganization of the site evaluation
committee and there's some differing
opinions on exactly how they should go
forward to the best of my knowledge this
is not included in there but if this
committee was so uh desired I would have
no problem with incorporating this with
that bill so we only have to deal with
one piece of legislation it's necessary
but it doesn't have to be a standalone
Bill and thank you for bringing that to
our attention that's a good point as
usual
representative McWilliams has a question
that right now you're saying the SEC
tends to drag projects out make them
take too long have onerous and
unnecessary rules it sounds like your
testimony has been really focused on
streamlining the process so we're not
there right now but if we were to enable
um five megawatts of solar across the
state for any developer who wanted to do
that would this bill then make it easier
for solar to be installed
um well I'm not a solo installer so it's
a little difficult for me to say that
but I would think that anytime you
remove additional regulations would make
it easier and it would be it would take
the things that really aren't your main
to a solar project that may be germane
to a wind project especially a small
solar project I remember if it's that
size it doesn't have to go to the site
evaluation committee it's a 30 megawatts
or bigger or at the request of the
governing agency such as the selectman
or mayor or city councils so most of the
time to be quite honest it would have no
effect on five megawatts one way or the
other because they're not under the site
evaluation committee unless for some
reason somebody decides to do it and
then the site evaluation committee would
have to vote to accept it but but
anytime you you if let's just say it was
a 30 megawatt solar system which would
be under this it would be less
burdensome because it'd be less
requirements and again I'm not saying
that everything that's specified in the
bill is bad I'm saying what the bill
originally said was is it only applies
to wind and if we want to look at other
projects and say well I'm going to take
not a b and c but maybe D and F and
apply it to solar then we should do that
but we should do it through the
legislative process not because some
bureaucrat decided it was a good idea
follow-up
so it's
rules other rsas would it make sense in
your opinion to to do a study on this to
really look at the nuts and bolts of
what it's applying to and how to how to
fix this for all energy projects well I
mean that could be a follow-up I guess
if someone wanted to look into that as a
a response to passing this bill but the
main function of the bill is to say
let's get rid of the administratively
created rules that don't reflect the law
and then if we wanted to come back and
say okay now that we've gotten those out
of there because they don't be there
they don't have the authority to do it
but they did it anyways
um now maybe we want to look at that and
and reassign some of those but reassign
them through the legislative process not
through the administrative rulemaking
process which was clearly exceeded in
this case thank you
right
concurrent with
or congruent to the question
representative McWilliams asked should
this bill contain a provision to create
a study committee to study this question
and see which rules should be revised
and or put into new legislation I would
certainly have no opposition to that
whatsoever
okay
all right seeing no further questions
for the prime sponsor we'll Now call on
the next person who has submitted a pink
card on this
Bill and that's Meredith Hatfield
representing the nature conservancy
Conservancy
and Miss Hatfield it's good to see you
again for long time members of the
committee
we will uh
recall that um
Miss Hatfield was once the consumer
advocate here in the state so welcome
nice to see you thank you very much
chairman Vos it's good to be back
Meredith Hatfield for The Nature
Conservancy
um
we I did Mark opposed to the bill
because we did want to raise just a few
cautionary comments but I did want to
start off by saying that we agree
wholeheartedly with representative
Harrington that the state will need
significant additional new energy
resources particularly as he pointed out
as we Electrify buildings and our
transportation systems
however
these rules We Believe were crafted
carefully with a lot of public input by
folks who might be impacted by projects
they were approved by jlcar the joint
legislative committee on administrative
rules which some of you may have sat on
so we think that
if there is a concern that the committee
is going Beyond its Authority that it
would be more appropriate to inquire
perhaps with the office of legislative
services or with JL Carr to perhaps
conduct a proceeding I'm not that
familiar with the JL Carr rules but
there might be an Avenue
to go through that committee my
assumption when I see a rule that's made
it through JL Carr is that it is within
the statutory authorization that you've
given to an agency and if you look at
rules you can actually see the statutory
site typically in rules that have been
approved by JL Carr
thank you to representative Thomas for
bringing up House Bill 609 which I think
it will be coming before your committee
soon it strikes us as making sense to
perhaps hold this bill and consider it
in the context of the larger overhaul
that is proposed in in chairman vosa's
bill so that you could consider these
issues together
um I think another option would be to
actually file a petition with a site
evaluation committee itself
um asking it to conduct this inquiry and
consider whether their rules are
appropriately drafted and I'm sure that
there would be a lot of folks who
propose energy projects as well as folks
with other interests who would be likely
interested in participating
if there was such a process
and I also just wanted to point the
committee to RSA
162h16 which is the current findings and
certificate issuance section in the
current SEC law which um you know has
language about the types of
considerations that the SEC should
should consider when it's considering
whether to issue a certificate it talks
about not unduly in interfering with
orderly developments no unreasonable
adverse effects on a range of topics
so I I do think that the SEC that you've
created the SEC to be an expert agency
to consider things you know that frankly
would be pretty complicated and take a
lot of time for for legislators to to uh
consider so so I also do think that
there may be times when
uh party in an SEC proceeding proposes
something and the committee thinks it's
a reasonable thing to add to a
certificate and sometimes all of the
parties to a case might agree so that
you know the committee does have some
Authority I think to consider general
public health and safety and other
issues thank you
thank you that's great input
I hadn't thought about appealing
directly to the SEC to modify its rules
but that certainly is another way to
accomplish the same
goal
unless it doesn't work of course any
further questions representative Summers
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question this is just a
clarification for myself uh the uh
is it not the job of the legislature to
to
um
to understand and change and refrain a
uh bring in I guess if a agency
misinterprets a law to actually go
follow what's actually in the law and
not what's written in some rule
foreign
yes I think that when you're a party to
an agency proceeding you have several
options one of them is to appeal the
agency finding to a court and what you
would be asking the court to do is look
at the legislative intents so I think
there are a few different Avenues you
can take if an agency does something if
you're an applicant or if you're seeking
a permit and and you don't like the
outcome there are different options but
certainly I think the legislature for
example on on the issue of sound the
legislature certainly can clarify
um you know what what you meant when you
told an agency to ensure that sound
impacts you know didn't interfere with
someone's enjoyment of their property or
something like that or a business that
was near a proposed energy facility
um I guess I would caution
you know the reason we have agencies
like Des or doe or the SEC is because
they
you know they take the time they have
the time to put people under oath and
have expert Witnesses come in and so
when it comes to you know what's the
decibel level you know that to me is
something that you would leave to an
agency now if you saw the agency setting
a limit of zero decibels for all the
energy projects obviously you know we're
not going to get any builds so I you
know I do think that that there
certainly I mean you you write the laws
of the state so certainly there's a
major role for you to set policy
Direction
um but I do think there's also a role
for the expertise that an agency can
consider
follow up
thank you Mr chairman
um so wouldn't this uh Bill be a way
another way of the legislature actually
clarifying the intent of the law
I I do think it could be I think some of
the language
um
you know sort of proclaiming that things
are beyond the law
might be a little bit challenging for
the SEC to
I I think it's not
perfectly clear what you would like them
to do so I think if you wanted to pass
this bill you know it certainly could be
revised to reflect you know your
specific intent on these different
topics
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh some of us
Hatfield or are there any particular
rules uh identified here that uh you
don't believe should be changed
I can't speak to the specifics of the
visual assessment or the sound
assessment but I do know that for a lot
of stakeholders those rules are very
important so that when they engage in a
site evaluation committee process
you know there's there's sort of
guidelines or there's a framework where
people can ask the SEC for certain
outcomes
um so I don't I don't have a specific
issue with any of the rules as they
currently exist
follow-up
so uh sound assessment for a solar panel
installation
is legitimate or or not
I I don't know if the committee has
required that
um I can't speak to any specifics about
that I'm sorry
thank you
representative Harrington uh no you
can't ask a question I'm not going to
ask you a question I just wanted to
State a clarification of the bill okay
clarification so so one thing that
people are aware of this bill does not
limit the authority of the site
evaluation committee as I stated in the
past for example on decommissioning the
site evaluation committee imposed that
as a requirement for the permit it
wasn't mandated by law all the bill does
it says the remove the mandates and
leave the discretion of the committee
decide like is just brought up yes we
want we're going to have the law
requires us to have a sound evaluation
for a windmill but not for a solar
facility because there's no need for it
it doesn't if they wanted to there'd be
nothing that would prevent them from
doing that it simply says that they uh
it doesn't restrict The Authority just
says they don't have to because that was
never the intent of the original Law
thank you for that clarification
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair and thank you uh for taking
my question so would it be your view or
your opinion that
um these rules do not exceed the
legislative Authority that was provided
by the legislature
it's my view and as I said before
um because they were approved by JL Carr
and that is such a rigorous process that
would be my view
um
you know I I think
representative Harrington might he can
correct me if I'm wrong but I think what
he might be getting at is the
application of rules to cases that he
thinks the committee doesn't have
Authority for so for example
um
on line 11 he refers the bill refers to
a site 30105 requiring
um visual impact assessments for all
facilities and on line 12 the bill says
such assessment is required for wind
energy systems only
um
so I I think if the rules have been
approved by JL Carr that the committee
did have the authority to promulgate
them
thank you
seeing no further questions I'd like to
thank Miss
Hatfield for being here this morning and
uh testifying to the committee thank you
is there anyone else
uh in attendance today who would like to
say something about this bill
seeing none I guess we shall
close the public hearing on House Bill
176 and representative closure will give
us a briefing on
the blue sheet responses to this bill
thank you chairman rules
House Bill 176 the blue sheet
is pro zero
against con zero against
online
one pro
what if
41 against
okay thank you
well this is unexpected I really didn't
anticipate that um
this hearing would only last a half hour
otherwise I would have scheduled it for
a half hour
but unfortunately we cannot change a
noticed public hearings time so we will
have to wait until 11 o'clock
before we can begin the
public hearing on House Bill 208
is there any member of the committee who
has anything that they would like to
discuss since we have apparently some
free time representative notter yes I
would like to request that we have a
caucus a republican caucus or maybe the
Democrats can have their own caucus
somewhere else
that's a good idea so
we will recess the committee until 11
o'clock
and allow individual caucuses to do
anything they feel they must we will
resume at 11 o'clock thank you
everyone 11 o'clock time to start the
hearing the public hearing on House Bill
208.
and I'm going to call to the
front table
representative will Darby who will
introduce the bill
he is a co-sponsor and he is taking the
place of Representative Jackie
who was injured over the weekend and
could not be with us today so good
morning representative Darby and welcome
to sdne
thank you chairman Vose thank you
members of the committee
as chairman Vose mentioned my name is
Will dark well Darby I'm from Nashua
Ward 8 I am co-sponsoring House Bill 208
I had intended to to
testify before this bill and and wrote
up a paper but and you know in sake of
time I'm going to read representative
cutchen's testimony instead um I have
submitted my own testimony online and
via email if you would have the
opportunity to uh to read through that
um
so I'm gonna I'm just gonna read uh what
she was intending to to state
I got representative
since we have a written copy of her
testimony rather than reading it could
you summarize it
because we can read it at our Leisure
rather than have you reading it to us
would that be possible or would you
prefer to read it
um
I unfortunately I don't think I will do
it do do justice I have read it several
times myself but I'm not sure that I'll
be able to summarize it completely
okay understood go right ahead and read
it I appreciate that thank you you bet
good morning colleagues and esteemed
guests for the record my name is
Jacqueline Gretchen and I represent
words two four five and seven in
Manchester here in the New Hampshire
house
I'm exceedingly sorry that I cannot be
here today to introduce this important
bill in person but as the wise man once
said I see is dicey and the ankle
surgery waits for no man but the
orthopedist
I am sponsoring this bill first and
foremost because the people of New
Hampshire want the state to have a
climate plan
this essential this is essentially
identical to bills that were introduced
in the last two sessions in 2020 as
House Bill 1664 it passed the house with
a margin of 197 to 123 but died at covet
Senate a coveted death in the Senate
last term as House Bill 172 it was
tabled along with many other bills from
our committee
however the public support for both of
these bills was overwhelming there were
310 people signed in to support House
Bill 172 when it was heard in 2021 and
only 30 against all but four of whom
were either elected officials or fossil
fuel lobbyists
we have a mandate from our constant
constituents to act on climate
secondly I'm sponsoring this bill
because I believe the state legislature
has a responsibility to protect our
residents
a safeguard and Safeguard New Hampshire
resources for future Generations
climate change is real and already
having an impact on New Hampshire
residents
businesses and the government
others testifying here today can speak
in details to these effects bajada
Summers negatively impact respiratory
health
warmer Winters are killer for tourism
and the revenue in the North country and
even a few inches of sea level rise
raise the cost of living and doing
business on the Seacoast
these effects will not only be will only
become more substantial over time
the science is clear that climate change
acceleration due to greenhouse gas
emissions is something that everyone who
lives in a developed country contributes
to and it's something that we will all
need to contribute to slowing we have a
responsibility to our children and
grandchildren and the other future
citizens of the state to act on climate
with that said I recognize that not
everyone on this committee agrees with a
98 of earth scientists
on the role of greenhouse gas greenhouse
gases in driving climate change
so let's talk about the money instead
there's a substantial evidence that
Renewables and low-carbon Technologies
in general are on a learning curves or
excuse me representative I'm going to
have to uh interrupt you here
we have a limited amount of time to
discuss this bill
and regrettably
representative cretian's testimony seems
to be about climate change rather than
the substance of this bill I think what
the committee members would really like
to hear is
what this bill does and how it does it
and
whether or not that's something that we
should consider doing
so
I'm going to ask you to forego
reading the rest of her testimony we can
read that at our Leisure and I'm going
to ask you instead if you could
discuss some of the specifics of the
bill what does it actually do
and
why should we consider doing that action
sure
thank you
so the the as stated in the bill it sets
up greenhouse gas emission goals for the
state and a climate action plan what
that means as I read the bill and as I
have discussed with representative
cutchen is that all is that the
departments in the state will have that
are that have control over
um and have influence over greenhouse
gas emissions will end up setting up a
um greenhouse gas objectives and goals
and and the Department of Environmental
Services will measure progress towards
those goals
I believe the reason that
um representative kretchen was talking
about the progress towards renewable
energies is because the developmental
Department of Environmental Services
will
apply those that that experiential curve
towards the towards the plan that they
put forth
okay thank you very much
I'm going to suggest that members of the
committee forego questions of
Representative Darby and uh
let us listen to some of the other folks
who want to testify on this bill the
Department of
Environmental Services we have another
representative who would like to testify
I have seven cards here already so we're
going to have to start limiting people
to two to three minutes very soon here
so I'd like to move on if that's okay
with you representative Darby yes thank
you
thank you very much
so I'll call next representative Jared
and I'm not sure if this is Sullivan or
Sully
Sullivan okay representative Jared
Sullivan
representing Grafton District 2.
thank you Mr chairman
yeah I'm here representing Grafton
District which is Bethlehem and
Franconia up in Northern New Hampshire
so the North country as we like to call
it oftentimes we feel like we're ignored
up there regardless of our party when
we're because most of the population
being down there we have a few people
representing us and we do have a unique
set of needs up there that oftentimes
aren't thought about down here in
southern more populated part of the
state my district specifically has Canon
located in it but also we have a big
industry with snowmobiling hunting
fishing and the majority of the people
my constituents are served by Wells not
by sewer or or water systems and all of
these things have are being threatened
by climate change and so I'm very much
in support of a bill that can help
reduce this um the ski industry has
shortened by I believe nearly a week we
have a lot of moose that are dying you
can look at this you can look this up
yourself because snow is happening later
and later every year the ticks are
killing off infant moose without a born
and I believe the last study I read was
that 70 of the moose in Maine didn't
make it through the winter last year
newborn moose didn't make it through the
winter so I'm in support of this bill it
impacts my district impacts Northern New
Hampshire impacts maple sugar industry
up there which is the biggest part of
the state that produces Maple sugars up
by me so these are all things that are
negatively impacted and you know it's
it's oftentimes things that maybe people
aren't thinking so I'm just trying to
provide another perspective that this
that climate change is real it's
negatively impacting everybody and it's
really hurting the livelihoods of some
of the people in my community a lot of
people in my we had a drought Last
Summer we've had a drought every summer
now for the last three four years and
numerous constituents have run out of
water and the some people can't drink
the water so they have to go and and
fill up at these local Springs and
they're just trickling out I mean those
lines getting water at one point in the
summer so with that I'll wrap up my
testimony and have it take any questions
if anybody has any
great thank you representative we
appreciate you being here we uh I will
ask you a quick question sure uh
pertaining specifically to the bill
you mentioned water issues in the North
Country you mentioned tick problems in
the North Country
Etc
how do you see what can you point to
specifically in this bill that will help
address some of those issues sure I
think yeah so the the idea is going
after the climate change issue more
broadly so if we can do our part I know
it's a global issue and so we have to
work globally but we can't we are part
of the global ecosystem so if we're
going to ignore New Hampshire that's
certainly not going to support anybody
else anywhere else in the in the world
trying to do their part and so we need
to reduce the amount of missions that
were happening and that's what this bill
aims to do and that's why I'm in support
of it
okay great any further questions for the
representative
seeing none I thank you for your testing
thank you Mr chairman
next I'll call on
rep Mr Michael Fitzgerald from the
Department New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services for his testimony
on this bill
morning again Mr chairman members of the
committee Mike Fitzgerald assistant
director of the Department of
Environmental Services air Resources
Division
we are the division of Des that would be
primarily tasked with most of the work
that's required in this bill Des does
not take a position on the uh on the
merits of the bill itself
um however we would like to point out a
couple of concerns
first of all by way of context Des was
uh very significantly involved in the
development of the 2009 climate action
plan that is still in existence today
many of whose recommendations
um uh are still supported at this point
that plan involved probably almost a
two-year process several Des staff uh
there was a 29-member task force that
the governor appointed to oversee the
development of that plan
and it required significant resources
most of which at that time were paid for
by funds from a major national
settlement on air pollution with major
power plants in the midwest that EPA
allocated some of that funding to Des
and therefore we were able to have
positions available to support that
support that work you might notice that
the fiscal note on this bill indicates
that we would probably that funding has
been used and is is now gone so
um this bill does not allow allocate any
additional funding for Staffing to do
the work that's planned in this bill and
so we would probably need a at least two
maybe more like three uh additional
staff to accomplish the work that's
required in this bill and
um as I noted there's there's no
appropriation also the timelines in the
bill are given the scope and magnitude
of the task and the potential economic
impacts of a significant
well thought out climate action plan
those potential economic impacts to be
considered
in the development of that plan would
require a significant amount of economic
analysis that our department does not
have the capability for so therefore we
would probably want to rely on some type
of a a consultant to to assist us with
that type of economic analysis that work
was done
external to The Climate action plan and
it was funded by the charitable
Foundation back in the two the
development of the 2009 plan we worked
closely with consultants and the
development of that but we did not do
the work ourselves
so in in essence basically we don't feel
the time frames contemplated in this
plan are sufficient
for for us to do a meaningful uh job and
uh do all the work that's anticipated
under the bill and second we do not have
the Staffing and resources and would
would certainly need
um
some type of allocation to do that work
we don't have those staff available
today that we had 10 years ago
so with that
um I'll be happy to take any questions
thank you Mr Fitzgerald for being here
and submitting your testimony on this
bill today yes by the way I did some I
did give a letter I passed a letter out
to each one summarizing my testimony or
thank you testimony and I do have a
couple of questions about your Lo your
letter certainly
your letter mentions three full-time
equivalent positions would those be
permanent
positions going forward or just would
would they just be temporary I wouldn't
development of a plan at least one if
not two of those positions would
probably be long term because the bill
does require continuous
um
uh reporting on greenhouse gas emissions
and so on so depending on the amount of
work that needed to be done I would I
would say at least one of those would be
a a long-term position and the other two
would be necessary for the during the
development of the plan which would
probably take
uh best guess on my part would be a two
two-year effort
um the bill does require that we conduct
public listening sessions that involves
going out holding hearings
you know all kinds of of effort um and
then coalescing all of that information
and and developing a report and then
putting that out to public comment as
well so I would say two years would be a
minimum necessary to get that
work that would be very aggressive
as a follow-up to that your letter also
says that implementation of a climate
plan will likely have an economic impact
on the state including energy costs for
residents businesses and manufacturers
as well as towns schools counties Etc
do you imagine that influence on energy
costs would be an increase in those
costs
um so it would be very difficult to say
at this time because it would depend on
the plan that was developed obviously
but I would suspect that there might be
short-term uh impacts to
and increases but in the development of
the 2009 climate plan we basically
determined that most of the measures
were ultimately cost saving measures but
that cost savings would accrue over time
your letter also mentions that it will
likely result in Workforce changes does
that mean layoffs
no I think um I I think what we've seen
is uh changes that you know for instance
people who might be employed in the
fossil fuel industry if there was a move
to Renewables might move you know need
re-education and move over into uh
development of of renewable energy types
or or things such as that but
um I don't again the client the 2009
climate action plan we'd be happy to
come speak to a committee or
subcommittee uh on the plan itself but
the 2009 plan I think envisioned uh that
there would be positive economic
um changes I wouldn't certainly would
not say there would be no
dislocation there might be some certain
disruption but the net there would be
overall positive benefits to the economy
and to employment
and finally as someone who's been
involved in these kinds of processes for
many many years would it be your
opinion that a bill that didn't have an
appropriation in it would be rejected by
the finance committee
uh I would certainly imagine so sir
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
you've listed several reasons to be
against this bill yet you say Des takes
no position so what are the reasons that
Des would not even take a position given
all the negative that you just told us
well as I mentioned in my opening
statement I don't believe Des
does not disagree with the basic premise
of the bill that the climate planning is
is necessary and important our concerns
are the fact that we don't have the
staff and the resources to do it at this
point so I would not say that that
results in US opposing the bill
but we certainly could not say we
support it as it stands because of the
fiscal impacts and the Staffing and
resource concerns that I've outlined so
I think we've tried to maybe thread the
needle a little bit here
okay representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um in the letter
um can you just clarify is commissioner
Scott
saying that a 14 year old climate plan
document is sufficient for 2023 and
going forward
I don't believe so I think what we're
saying though is that that plan was well
thought out well well planned many of
the recommendations in that plan have
not come to fruition I've been adopted
so
um I'm I think the plan could certainly
uh stand updating
um but uh many of it's concerned many of
its uh analyzes and recommendations
would still stand today follow up follow
up thank you
um and do you know if money from the
infrastructure bill could cover a
project like this uh I don't know about
the infrastructure bill but
um
the uh recent Ira I forget the term but
um uh EPA is uh considering that they're
taking comment right now they received a
significant amount of funding for
greenhouse gas
uh and climate planning efforts and uh
um they are taking public comment on how
to allocate those and specifically
whether to allocate uh certain of those
funds to to States we are we have been
active in that comment process and we
expect to hear something in the next
couple of months as to whether EPA
funding may be may be available for this
um this type of an effort but at this
point in time we certainly are not
secure in that thank you very much
inflation reduction act I'm sorry
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your reoccurring appearance before this
committee
um
could you could you you talked you
talked a little bit about the the
challenges the costs associated with
climate change and and implementing a a
plan
um you know enter a potentially in
impact on energy costs can you talk a
little bit about the the opportunities
that addressing climate change can
present to that presents to our state
and our economy
uh representative remember we're here to
ask questions about the bill
we're not here to solve climate change
as a problem Mr chairman
I I'm I'm I'm I guess I'm I'm speaking
to the letter that we received where
there's a discussion of the costs of
climate change but I think we we've
heard it from
um Mr Fitzgerald that there are that
there are benefits as well
if you can answer that quickly uh
certainly I'll allow it certainly uh the
letter refers to economic impacts those
impacts can be both positive and
negative and in the 2009 climate plan we
certainly did uh identify a very
significant potential economic benefits
and overall the benefits were greater
than the uh than the potential costs
um but uh I when I say economic impacts
in the letter it does refer to both
positive and negative
representative McWilliams has a question
I met from 2009 and
and there are pieces that were not
implemented what could we do to
implement those pieces other than you
know this it sounds like really
complicated and expensive two-year
effort to do this bill what could we do
instead to implement those pieces from
2009 that haven't been implemented
well the 2009 plan was adopted as a
result of a climate change policy task
force that was established by an
executive order by Governor Lynch that
task force gave no authority to to
implement any actions
um opposition has always been that that
Authority would need to be author would
need to be provided for and authorized
by the legislature and for instance the
regional greenhouse gas initiative our
participation and continued
participation in that
was authorized by the legislature
things such as the renewable portfolio
standard other other Energy Efficiency
measures Etc that have been adopted over
time have all been authorized by the
legislature and so as was discussed in
the last bill on the site evaluation
committee the legislature would need to
provide specific authorization
uh to the uh the department or other
agencies whatever to implement specific
portions of the plan that would
uh that that plan had it was a plan but
it had no specific authorization to it
follow-up follow-up
um so so just so I understand this
you're saying that we do need to do some
kind of legislation in order to
implement those recommendations from the
2009 plan is there something that you
could tell us that would be less
expensive or require less staff or
um could could somehow pass what seems
to be you know a serious concern about
cost
well again the staff that worked on that
plan are no longer with the Department
because that that funding was provided
by a settlement of funds from EPA
so even if I wanted to do something
similar to what we did before I I can't
I can't do that now
because those staff are no longer with
us and and that funding is is gone
I would have since 2009
uh a lot of the this type of work that
we do has been funded by EPA but that
work has been funded level funded since
since uh 2010 and a grant that at one
point from EPA covered approximately 21
people today covers 12. so we our
staffing is actually less than what it
was at that time and
the staff that were specifically funded
to do this work are no longer with us
and have no uh and there's and there's
no funding for them even in the base EPA
grants now again as was mentioned under
the inflation reduction act there's
potential federal funds
um that would be available to states to
to hire specific staff but I would be
very hesitant to sit here and tell you
that I could undertake
even the most cursory climate action
plan based on the current funding and
resource situation within the department
thank you representative Doug Thomas has
a question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question although I'm not
sure a few answers but I would like to
get back to the bill actually and in the
bill
on the last page uh I think item number
three it says State entry policy does it
does this
with this rewrite
or cause to be Rewritten the the new uh
States 10-year energy plan that has just
come out I'm a little confused as to
what this would do and a doe it doesn't
seem to be here so I'm wondering if you
can comment on what that that paragraph
on state energy policy would do
I don't have specifics for you but I do
note that the bill says it shall repeal
RSA 37837
um and then and then that that section
is then reenacted as follows and so
this seems to me too in in legislation
establish an energy policy policy then
it would be up to the Department of
energy to determine whether
their current
uh energy strategy
um you know comports with the policy the
legislatures to establish the policy
then it would be up to the agency to
determine whether or not what they're
doing is currently would comport with
the revised policy follow up thank you
uh so to to be clear then this would
require the doe to do a review of their
plan all over again to see if it met
what the legislation here would would
tell them to do well I would point out
there are two separate plans one is a
climate action plan that was the 2009
the other is the state energy plan right
that is authorized currently authorized
in statute and I believe that the
statute requires every three years that
it be updated
um and uh but that's a task of the
Department of energy we obviously can
work with the Department of energy and
try to achieve some consistency and and
we we comment on their energy plan from
an environmental perspective uh we don't
comment on the on the energy policy from
a financial or or economic impact
perspective
okay thank you Mr Fitzgerald we're going
to move on here we have six people who
would like to testify and we only have
30 minutes left so
um we will next call on Wharton Sinclair
who is um from Sandwich New Hampshire to
testify and Mr Sinkler you have three
minutes thank you very much
um yeah as the chair uh mentioned I'm
from sandwich I'm here speaking on
behalf of myself and I think it's I I am
in support of this bill I think having a
plan for uh addressing climate change is
important uh one of the reasons is
economics
we are seeing increasing disruption from
climate change including economic
effects in our state already any
Industries which depend on snow and ice
this winter have taken a big hit and I
think there's a prognosis that that will
continue
as the disruptions become more severe
there is a possibility that Draconian
steps will be needed in the future and
we can position New Hampshire uh better
to uh to be in a better position when
that happens if and when that happens if
we have reduced our Reliance on fossil
fuels in the interim so a plan for New
Hampshire to do that to me is in line
with economic prudence and responsible
governance and I urge you to approve
this plan and to take the
recommendations that come with it and uh
and act to reduce our greenhouse gas
emissions which will reduce our
vulnerability
with respect to a need to reduce those
emissions there are other reasons that
are for example health related a lot of
bad health effects are due to emissions
of uh from fossil fuels particulate
emissions which cause really severe
health effects severe heat which is
really hard on our residents especially
older people and children there are also
National Security issues with our use of
fossil fuels right now we are indirectly
in a conflict with Russia and they
benefit when uh are when we use a lot of
fossil fuel and thereby keep the global
price for fossil fuels high so from a
national security point of view New
Hampshire can do its part and really
have an impact if we plan away from
these fossil fuels will benefit the
climate will benefit health will benefit
National Security I would particularly
urge the Republicans on the committee to
take a stand here and do what I believe
their constituents want of them which is
to take this issue seriously and to make
some substantive uh actions in the
direction of a responsible and uh
substantive uh set of actions to address
address climate change thank you very
much for your attention and I'd be happy
to take any questions that you have
thank you Mr Sinkler and thank you for
being respectful of our time limit
appreciate that questions for Mr Sinkler
representative McWilliams
thank you chair Bose and thank you for
your testimony Mr Sinkler can you just
explain what some of the benefits would
be if we were to adopt a climate action
plan I've heard a lot of negative about
cost and Staffing for Des and the fact
that it's 14 euros old and hasn't been
implemented what are some of the pros
well it depends really what the actions
recommended are but for example reducing
uh you know replacing the state vehicle
fleet vehicles in the state vehicle
Fleet and in Municipal uh vehicle fleets
with electric vehicles may have uh real
benefits they're cheaper to run you can
charge them at night when most of the
power is coming from Seabrook and we're
not using natural gas which we don't
produce anyway in our state uh you know
so that is an economic benefit as well
as having clean air and uh you know
reduce reliance you know the National
Security effects that I mentioned but
yes I think there are there are there
obviously it has to be part of the plan
to analyze the economic effects of a
initiative such as replacing vehicles uh
in in fleets with electric vehicles
um but that's a that's an example of the
type of thing that we could be doing uh
to and also installing more uh renewable
energy working with our utilities and
the Public Utilities Commission to
encourage the uh implementation of work
of more clean energy
that is you know when it's produced here
in New Hampshire it uh it's local it's
uh clean it's economical uh so many many
benefits including economical benefits
thanks okay thank you
so you know further questions from the
committee I'd like to thank you for
stopping by this morning and talking
with us thank you all very much and I'd
like to call next
on Joan Widner of Amherst
who's representing herself and Miss
Whitmer
I think we've already heard about
the need for this bill
to address climate change so rather than
restating that need if you could tell us
how specifically you think this bill
will will help we'd appreciate that well
I've submitted some written testimony
which is really addressing the health
implications of climate change I'm a
healthcare practitioner I'm a nurse
working for home health and hospice in
Merrimack and I see every day patients
that are dealing with exacerbations of
COPD and congestive heart failure as a
result of high heat index date days most
of New Hampshire homes are not equipped
with air conditioning and so these
patients suffer particularly badly we in
fact at home health and hospice have a
fan program where we'll bring a fan to a
home of a patient that is having
difficulty breathing but put that aside
prior to becoming a nurse I had a
25-year career in corporate finance and
accounting and I spent years developing
operational and business plans as well
as strategic plans and as everyone knows
a strategic plan needs to be updated
dated every three years we're dealing
with a climate change plan that was not
has not been updated since 2009 that's
untenable because every plan needs to be
modified over time because the events
and circumstances around those plans
change so it's just real Prudence to
modify plans over time and to make sure
that you're using the appropriate
mechanisms that are that are available
also I will Echo um my the prior
individual's testimony that most climate
change benefiting work is cost savings I
personally drive a hybrid car and I get
50 miles to the gallon I I'm looking
forward to the next car purchase to go
to full electric matter of fact a lot of
electric companies are now doing Net
Zero metering to allow individuals who
own vehicles to charge them at off-peak
hours so that they can then buy back
that energy during peak hours that their
batteries have that have not been used
so there's a lot of benefits solar
panels are cheaper to run
different kinds of light bulbs getting
rid of the incandescence and going to
the other kinds of both I can't think of
their names I'm drawing a blank on it
I'm not a technologist I'm a healthcare
practitioner and I know that with the
increase is in visits to the emergency
department that's costing us through our
Medicaid dollars because a lot of these
patients are coming to the emergency
room for treatment and so we have
savings there so I mean I again this is
all off the cuff based on my knowledge
of both business finance and Health Care
thank you for your time to speak I don't
want to talk to specifics in the bills
because that's not my area of expertise
but thank you I'll take questions
thank you very much appreciate you being
here and being respectful of our time
limitations thank you representative
Thomas has a question thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question just
for clarification uh uh when you were
introduced you said you were
representing yourself I am on the
written testimony though the The Heading
says New Hampshire health care workers
for climate action we're just a
volunteer group I'm a volunteer I'm just
a volunteer that happens to be
affiliated with the organization it's a
it's a non-profit group of of clinicians
who get together and we we want to
increase the voice of health care
workers on climate change and the impact
because While most people accept climate
change is real they don't recognize that
it's impacting them today it's impacting
their health thank you for that
clarification certainly
so to clarify representative Thomas's
question do you represent this group New
Hampshire no I just put it on their
letterhead because I just wanted to
promote the name of the organization
because we're here and we will probably
be talking not just me but other people
we're just volunteers we're no one's
paid so I don't think in representing
the group I'm speaking as an individual
certainly my business background has
nothing to do with the organization it's
just I'm a unique in healthcare workers
to have both backgrounds great thank you
for that clarification certainly
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming in
um based on your on your on your
business experience
um would would you agree or not agree
that you know one of the things that
really determines whether businesses are
going to invest in anything a project or
or a business
um really is is driven in law in in in
in in a large part by their
understanding of kind of the economic
um you know environment absolutely
unfortunately a lot of businesses make
most of their financial decisions based
on short-term issues but we're seeing
that change over time because long-term
issues are having a greater impact over
time for instance increase in cost in
health care is impacting
um will eventually impact if it hasn't
already I don't have the data in front
of me um Healthcare premium so that's
going to affect everyone it's going to
affect businesses
um there are a lot of issues and so you
have to make business decisions not only
based on short-term issues which is what
a business or an operation plan does but
also on long-term issues which is what
is strategic plan does and I liken this
plan to a strategic plan it looks at the
longer term picture and if we don't
start investing now as Mr Wharton uh I
didn't catch his last name Morton said
previously we're going to pay later
because the cost of mitigation is going
to be less in the near term than it will
be in the long term and we will be
seeing increased adverse weather events
it's it's 98 of the world scientists on
this agree on this fact
follow up just a quick follow-up so so
my my my point was that
um that this plan if if this plan if
this bill passed and if a climate action
plan was implemented
um would that not provide some better
Clarity to businesses that are thinking
about potentially investing in
um Alternative Energy Products
absolutely I mean and therefore you know
help generate that economic activity
that we've talked about I I completely
concur with that I think that if if
um the the state is moving in that
direction then businesses are going to
be prudent to do the same because don't
forget consumers are starting to demand
this there are investment funds out
there now that are looking at social
issues in terms of making Investments
and so some individuals who are taking
their hard-earned dollars to invest are
looking to invest in companies that have
a a positive perspective relative to
climate change and want to make an
impact on that so that is becoming an
issue and the consumer is making that an
issue thank you
okay thank you seeing no further
questions thank you for your time we
appreciate your being here
I'll call next to this to the testimony
table Mr Ken Wells of Andover New
Hampshire
former state representative welcome Mr
Wells good to see you again
thank you chairman Vose and thank you
members of the committee uh in advance
for a few moments of your kind attention
um I'm Ken Wells of Andover New
Hampshire
um I'd also like to express my thanks to
uh representative sellaway of Grafton
and Mr Sinkler and Ms Whitmer for
speaking about some of the challenges
that my region of New Hampshire faces as
well House Bill 208 provides climate
planning with an eye towards addressing
long-range economic
and environmental benefits those
economic benefits include tourism and
Forestry and quality of life things are
there that are especially important in
our sort of North Central uh part of New
Hampshire so why does New Hampshire need
a plan uh that HB 208 puts forward well
our current 10-year plan is a plan that
maintains the fossil fuel status quo and
this accelerates uh the deleterious
economic effects in the portion of State
that's the economic engine for tourism
and Forestry the the part of the state
that we are all from
there's another aspect to this you know
recently I spent part of my Tuesday
morning reading aloud to 18
four-year-old preschoolers children's
stories about empathy generosity and the
personal courage to do what's right
let's talk about HB 208 in the context
of generosity and the personal courage
to do what's right
there's an ideological school of thought
called Austrian capitalism measures all
values and benefits in terms of dollars
proponents would say that the economic
value of the status quo outweighs any
future intangible benefits
if you believe that so what cash value
would you put on our grandchildren's
quality of life
New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services projects that by
the time those four-year-olds reach my
age the climate of New Hampshire will
have changed to resemble that of North
Carolina today
those kids will say too bad our native
species were not resilient enough those
Carolina species don't grow to maturity
spawn and reseed fast enough to escape
the new to New Hampshire 800 miles north
in just 60 years
there will be a disaster there will be
extinctions
those kids will blame the Boomers
they'll blame the government they'll
look at your voting record they'll blame
you
do you want that to be your legacy
show us that you learned the lessons
about generosity and personal courage
that we try to teach to four-year-olds
representative in contrast to yes can I
interrupt you for just a second and ask
you to speak specifically to how the
bill
will address the issues that you're
talking about for example you've just
stated in in your testimony that
New Hampshire's climate in some number
of years from now will be like North
Carolina's well that's a prediction
but
most of the predictions that have been
made about climate change in the last
30 40 years have proved to be incorrect
I don't believe that so so why don't you
try to explain to us how this bill
addresses the goals that you want to
achieve specifically on the last page
talking about lines 11 and 12 achieving
the greenhouse gas emission goals
identified in RSA 125 and protect the
safety and health of the citizens the
physical environment of the state the
supply of Natural Resources for future
Generations
representative soloway talked about the
ticks and the and the the moose
population about the impacts the
negative impacts on tourist Industries
like skiing and foliage and things like
that we are already seeing the economic
impacts the the that are damaging uh New
Hampshire's economy
so we need an energy policy that that
needs to be developed in regard to the
short and long-term uh financial and
fiscal UH responsibilities that we have
we can't just look at the short term
uh
aspect of what it's going to cost us
today as opposed to doing nothing so I
think that we'll need to we need to have
a plan I think that house bill 208 is a
good step in the direction of
establishing a plan and a mechanism for
um
making sure that
we are we the state of New Hampshire are
not a laggard behind the other New
England states whose uh whose plans
include uh things to control greenhouse
gas emissions you know we are we are
running out of Runway so fast that ideas
of of you know some someday Technologies
uh that will save us are um are things
that don't meaningfully exist in reality
any more than perpetual motion does and
at this very moment we're hurtling down
a dead end runway on a flightless school
bus and on board are not just our
children but every every species on the
planet the status quo is no longer a
good option we need a plan and that plan
needs to agree uh it has to have an
agreement to get our foot off the
accelerator thank you very much
yes okay thank you appreciate that do we
have any questions representative
Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chairman so uh Mr Wells
you've gone over a bunch of potential
benefits but you've gone over no cost to
this what are the costs of this plan
I think that um uh Mr Fitzgerald talked
about what the Staffing costs would be
and until we have a plan uh I don't
think I could predict what those costs
uh would be but I know what the cost
will be if we do nothing things will
continue to deteriorate
thank you
so if you were building a house and you
went to the Builder and you said uh
please craft a plan for me to build this
house
would you not tell him
what you are
your budget for the house was
would you not give him some indication
about how much money you could afford to
spend
that budget would also have to include
what um what the performance of the
house should be like in the future and I
would uh you know I would budget so that
things like insulation to save energy
would be included in that and not simply
try to build uh some some box that has
the the maximum of square footage for
the the cheapest cost so I don't think
that's up to the Builder to determine
that that's up to the planner which
would be me the owner of the the house
we are the uh as well you as policy
makers uh own that decision
and you should have a way of planning
the future and not just continue with
the status quo because that's the the
path of least resistance
so you'd be comfortable with a plan that
had I'm sorry you'd be comfortable with
a plan that had an open-ended cost
structure
Bill calls for uh calls for a mechanism
for establishing a plan it doesn't uh it
does not uh establish the expended any
sort of things about expenditures in
order to I don't know uh you know build
nuclear reactors or or uh or you know
windmills or what have you to reduce
greenhouse gases but but this bill talks
about establishing a mechanism for
making that plan so it's like engaging
the architect not building the house
okay thank you representative Summers
has a question
thank you Mr chairman just a quick
question here um
knowing our Uh current electrical grid
the way it's powered the way it's
generated the power is generated
um how do you propose that we're going
to lower 20 in the next two years well
that's actually less than two years
um I think that you've answered the
question
um the the way that our grid is
currently powered uh will have to change
within two years
uh it could it I don't know where you
get two years uh in in the bill in the
bill it's actually States 1A at least 20
percent below 1990 level by 2025 which
would be two years
then we better get cracking
representative Harrington has a question
uh yes um sounds a bit what you're
talking about is let me just make sure I
get this correct a drastic change in the
method of producing electricity if we're
going to reduce those greenhouse gases
by 20 we're going to see a uh not only a
we're not going to have days like we did
in January where 40 of our electricity
was coming from oil uh we're not going
to have an average day where 60 is
coming from natural gas
so we're gonna have to replace them with
I would think solar and wind would be
the two major options since we
apparently don't want to build
transmission lines from Canada either
um what do you see as the pushback from
people on say if you want to replace a
600 megawatt gas plant you need about 20
000 Acres of solar panels what's what 20
000 acres is available in New England to
build solar panels on and where are we
going to put up hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of windmills without people
saying I don't want it near me because
it seems like wherever you propose it no
one wants it so
you know the the uh the acreage of of
solar power to to produce 100 of the
electricity that uh uh the state would
require is less than the acreage used
for baseball fields it's not as far as
the eye can see as what you're sounding
like you're imagining you know it's less
than the rooftops of single wide motor
homes in New Hampshire so you know it's
it's uh it's an attainable goal
um and I think that there are ways this
bill talks about
um uh removing some of the impediments
to um to building uh cleaner uh energy
infrastructure you know for example one
of the the things that I think that this
plan uh might uh uh support would be um
the the removal of the one megawatt uh
cap on the size of uh uh solar
installations you know much as the
community power has increased it to five
megawatts it would make it a much more
uh economically grid of feasible grid
scale thing but this is getting way out
head of what this bill talks about this
bill talks about creating the the
mechanism for planning for the future
not the plan
you need a follow-up representative
Harrington also
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um I'm referring to page one lines eight
through ten where it says New Hampshire
will see longer and hotter summer
shorter warmer Winters and more frequent
and more extreme precipitation events
Revolt resulting in both increased
flooding and drought in New Hampshire we
build our houses with wood would
obviously if it's exposed to a lot of
moisture is going to rot we're also
really bad at insulation so there's a
lot of leaking I'm wondering energy
leaking I'm wondering if you could speak
to the economic impact of climate change
on property value
well uh yes I can speak a little bit
about I'm not an expert in uh in real
estate but the
um the the longer hotter Summers the uh
uh are uh increasing the
um the uh likelihood of fire
um which in our heavily wooded part of
uh New Hampshire is is a real concern
um and uh uh you know the the
um
the amount of of uh uh you know rainfall
and things like that I think are are uh
really impacting
um uh homeowners that uh need to go out
and expend a serious amount of money to
drill a well because their their shallow
Wells have gone dried these are shallow
Wells that in my neighborhood some of
those are a hundred years old and have
been have been fine up until now
um and so you know I think that that
um you know there are real estate is
very complicated there are other other
pressures of course uh on that but but I
think that that climate change uh is is
going to impact the sorts of things that
uh that make New Hampshire quality of
life very good make uh New Hampshire a
tourist destination and make New
Hampshire a place that people want to
buy homes and that'll have the largest
impact I think on values of properties
thank you okay thank you representative
or former representative Wells for being
here today we're going to have to move
on because we have three more people who
would like to testify and I'll Now call
on Joseph quasnick to testify uh on
behalf of himself
I don't know if he will be testifying on
behalf of represent organizations he
represents or just for himself I plan to
testify for myself thank you great thank
you
Mr chairman in this committee thank you
for allowing me the time to testify
before you today
um
three minutes please three minutes thank
you very much
um just to give you a little bit about
my background I've worked in the area of
energy and environment for over 40 years
beginning as the vice president of
environment and climate change uh for
National Grid I've spent nine years on
the New Hampshire Electric Co-op board
three of those years as chairman and
I've also spent five years as a senior
energy advisor at series Incorporated in
Boston currently I'm a member of the
management team of the New Hampshire
Network for climate energy and
environment
I'll keep this short I support this bill
because one New Hampshire faces an
existential threat to the economy and
environmental future from global climate
change in this bill provides a path for
the state to rationally and economically
begin to address that challenge
in July 2022 the New Hampshire
Department of energy released its
long-awaited state energy strategy
unfortunately the strategy is not
actionable as all of the existed goals I
think there are 10 goals fail to provide
any metrics by which the department or
the public can achieve can determine
achievement of the goals and the
strategy barely mentions climate change
this bill provides actionable and
quantifiable goals by specifying
greenhouse gas emissions ruption
reductions over the next 27 years
including Net Zero greenhouse gas
emissions by 2050.
this bill also requires a New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services to
develop a plan to achieve the emissions
reductions
this plan should provide the blueprints
so sorely needed in New Hampshire to
begin to deal with the climate change
challenge
this plan should go far beyond the state
energy strategy in delivering needed
changes including the way New Hampshire
sources energy how it plans its
Transportation future and monitorize
excuse me moderate modernizes its
electric grid
this bill in concert with another bill
in the senate senate Bill 166 an act
relative electric grid modernization
can result in needed modernization of
the New Hampshire distribution grid as
we all know a major source of greenhouse
gas emissions is our energy use
modernization of the New Hampshire
distribution grid and finally it will
provide a much needed unified approach
to meeting the Energy Efficiency needs
of low moderate income citizens
introducing market-based electric rate
structures including transactive energy
techniques and Technology
expanding the development of renewable
and deployment of renewable energy
that electrifying Heating and Cooling in
New Hampshire and a number of other
nations with this within the state
this bill will also provide a needed
training for New Hampshire's Workforce
to meet the technical challenges the
state will face as it meets the
challenges of climate change
lastly this bill will finally begin to
reduce our dependence on out-of-state
electric generating sources and will
keep New Hampshire's hard-earned earned
energy dollars in state rather than
continue to send them to corporations
outside our borders 30 seconds thank you
for the opportunity to test for it
testifying the bill and I'm prepared to
take questions
thank you
okay seeing no questions from the
committee we'll move along
oh didn't see your hand quick question
from representative partial thank you
chair is your have you made your
testimony available and have I missed it
or could you make it available and could
I ask that of the same of the former uh
person to testified well my testimony
was submitted electronically this
morning this morning yes that's pretty
good luck thank you thank you
okay seeing no further questions I'd
like to Now call on Dominic
Osmond of Manchester
representing 350 New Hampshire
three minutes
thank you chair
hello uh
my name is Dominic Osmond I live in
Manchester I am a registered lobbyist
here representing 350 New Hampshire we
are a climate Justice organization
I am here to speak in support of HB 208
and I strongly recommend that this
committee votes in favor of this bill to
ensure that New Hampshire is not left
behind by neighboring states as has been
mentioned New Hampshire is uh operating
on the climate action plan that was
drafted back in 2009 in the region of of
New England the next most recent climate
action plan was from 2016 and that was
released by Rhode Island uh speaking
personally it does not feel that good to
be lagging that far behind such as Rhode
Island and the rest of this region
during this past summer and now during
the winter we have been paying
record-breaking utility bills both both
for electrical generation as well as
natural gas for heating
this increased cost of living has been
very difficult to deal with for many
families and residents of the state we
cannot remain unprepared in terms of
taking advantage of and expanding and
cheapening zero emission energy sources
failure to do so will hurt New Hampshire
working people what I really see as the
biggest benefit of this climate action
plan are the bill suggesting such is
that it will prepare us help us prepare
for changes that we know will be coming
we can't decide whether or not fossil
fuel power generation is going to be
phased out in the next 20 years that is
going to be happening by other states by
other corporations and by other decision
makers and it is incumbent upon us to be
prepared for that and not be left behind
I can't tell you the number of people
I've spoken to are concerned not only
with the long-term impacts of climate
change such as the increased flooding
and whether in extreme weather events
that have been mentioned previously but
also those increased costs of living uh
not being able to to power and heat
homes as well as being worried about uh
whether or not roads will be able to to
be passable whether that be from from
flooding or from just uh breaking down
and not being being updated
uh for these reasons and many other I
would like to again reiterate my support
for for this bill and encourage
everybody on the committee to vote in
favor of setting the greenhouse gas
emissions reductions goal as well as
establishing a climate action plan and
perhaps as well amending it to recommend
an appropriation for what sounds like a
criminally underfunded and understaffed
Department of Environmental Services uh
thank you very much this concludes my
testimony and I will take any questions
thank you very much and I
um
I'm pleased that you respected our time
constraints of course
doesn't look like anybody has any
questions so I'll thank you for being
here thank you and I'll call on the
final uh testifier for on this bill
that's Meredith Hatfield of The Nature
Conservancy welcome back Miss Hatfield
pretty much chairman Vos and members of
the committee I'm going to start my
timer but I know you'll interrupt me if
I start to go over like many of the
prior speakers The Nature Conservancy
strongly supports this bill and as
someone who was able to participate in
the 2009 climate action plan process
myself and also TNC had a seat on that
body I can say it really was an amazing
opportunity to bring together interests
from around the state including many
agencies of state government from
transportation to insurance and then des
and and the energy agencies it really
started to help us get a picture of what
we needed to address and for things like
insurance which are you know I'm not an
insurance person but it was fascinating
to learn from the New Hampshire
Department of Insurance about the things
they're thinking about with respect to
climate change
we see a strong climate plan as
something that can direct investment it
can help us protect our infrastructure
it can help Drive Innovation and one
area that's particularly of importance
for the nature conservancy and our
partners is the resilience and
adaptation piece we are seeing impacts
on the ground every day in our state and
we are working closely with state
agencies and with municipalities to help
them figure out how do we protect our
infrastructure and how do we make
smarter Investments so that our
infrastructure can handle that 100-year
flood that is no longer every hundred
years but it's happening you know every
few years in some places
with respect to the funding as someone
who served in state government in
several capacities I certainly can
relate to not having resources we do
think that the two pieces of major
federal legislation that have passed
over the last 18 months
um bil and Ira as they are known could
have significant potential resources to
be able to fund this effort and I think
there are a lot of Partners including
possibly the New Hampshire charitable
Foundation who might be willing to put
our heads together and come up with the
funding necessary for this
several speakers during your orientation
including all of our utilities spoke
about the need for our state to have a
plan and to me that is a clear call for
this kind of work you also heard it from
the regional grid operator and we also I
think heard it from the power generators
that clean energy is the future and we
need to figure out a path to get there
that's affordable
with respect to the RSA section of the
bill that refers to
um
uh
378.37 that my understanding is that is
the current statute
um that guides uh largely the puc
in ensuring lease cost energy planning
and I think obviously the sponsors can
can talk about their goals here but I
think this the major changes to add in
section c so this is um page four of the
bill on line 11. so the cost
Effectiveness reliability diversity safe
safety and health those
requirements are already in that law and
one of the changes this section makes is
to add in the greenhouse gas emission
goals
um one small thing is that there are a
few references in this bill to the
office of strategic initiatives which
clearly would need to be updated to the
Department of energy
representative Summers question about
the 20 reduction because that is a
reduction from 1990 levels I think we're
actually doing pretty well there I think
between Reggie and our efficiency
programs and some of our other
successful policies and programs I think
we might be pretty close to that but I'm
sure Des could answer that more fully 30
seconds
I think that was
um all that I wanted to cover thank you
very much
thank you very much questions
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair and thank you for coming
back again
um as somebody that's worked in the
public policy arena for years
um can you speak to
um the influence that
um the existence or non-existence of a
plan has on on
um
in in
um just moving moving people along and
encouraging Innovation and and and ways
to address address a particular problem
and can you can you comment on how that
lack of a plan has really what what
influences that had on how we've been
able to address some of the challenges
and opportunities in climate change
thank you um you know I think this bill
the structure that this lays out would
be extremely helpful for agencies all
across the state and and as I referenced
participating in the 2009 process
breaking down those silos and also
seeing all of the interconnected ways
that agencies could be working together
whether it's Transportation or Energy
Des our business agency having that plan
and being able to develop it together as
a group is extremely helpful on Guiding
agency work
um I you know I do think if the
committee is not comfortable moving
forward with this bill as currently
drafted I would urge you to retain it
and work on it more it if you feel like
it needs more work I think there are a
lot of people who would be happy to
contribute to that process
um and I think there is a famous saying
about how if you don't if you don't plan
you can't manage what you have and I
think that's certainly the case here
thank you
additional questions
seeing none I want to thank you for
being here to testify on this bill
chairman Vos I'm sorry I just thought of
one other thing um if you don't mind
representative Thomas referred to the
the interplay between RSA 378 and then
the state energy strategy statute and I
did just want to give you the reference
for that so the state energy strategy is
separately required in law under RSA
12p7
excellent thank you you're welcome
representative Wendy Thomas actually has
a question yeah can we just clarify that
that was representative Doug Thomas's
comment not mine
well done
accomplished okay so now we're done
thank you very much so I'm going to
close the public hearing on
House Bill 208 and ask representative
closure to give us the blue sheet sign
in information on this bill
uh thank you chair House Bill 208 the
blue sheet was three in support one
against Bill online in support was 166.
and against was 12.
okay thank you very much
with that we will conclude the morning
activity of science technology and
energy for Monday
the 30th of January
will be officially on recess until 1 30
at which time we will take up House Bill
443 establishing a commission to study
the withdrawal of New Hampshire from ISO
New England we will see you then
have a nice lunch
okay it is 1 30 according to my
whiz-bang Gadget here
and uh so I would like to open the
public hearing on House Bill 443 which
is a bill establishing a commission to
study the withdrawal of New Hampshire
from ISO New England
and I would like to call on the primary
sponsor of the bill
representative J.D Bernardi to introduce
this legislation good afternoon Mr Clerk
thank you Mr chair and committee uh as
indicated I'm JD Bernardi I serve the
southeast corner of New Hampshire I come
from Southampton I surprised to support
uh House Bill 443 and act establishing a
commission to study withdrawal of New
Hampshire from ISO New England so the
bill has basically three main components
one who all the members are two what the
task is which is to enumerate and assess
the advantages and disadvantages of
withdrawal from ISO New England and
becoming an independent grid operator
Market administrator and power system
planner and the third item is to issue a
report by the end of the end of the year
excuse me
so Connecticut and Maine have also
conducted similar assessments I think
that gives us a leg up if we would do
this we can read their reports and
understand what their issues were
particularly uh well both pros and cons
but I want to turn to my rationale for
submitting this bill
first is
in my campaign one of the key issues
that I faced was explaining to
constituents why there was skyrocketing
costs of electric power it was a
universal issue in almost any door I
knocked
now if New Hampshire were to be its own
ISO group or withdrawal it would get the
full benefit of the sebrick nuclear
power station so you see in one of these
handouts I have here what's the peak
power in New Hampshire it's a little
over
um
2000 or 2100 uh megawatts what does
Seabrook produce about 1200. so that's
about 60 percent of the power for New
Hampshire similarly we have hydro that
we share with uh Vermont we have half of
that and a lot of small-scale hydro
so
there's an opportunities to
substantially reduce the cost of power
to New Hampshire because we have we have
good base load that would cover most
most of our cost
second reason
virtually all new capacity being uh
considered by ISO New England is uh is
all Renewables
and as they indicated in their report to
us
it would require fast responding sources
like grid scale energy resources to
balance the variability of Renewables
meaning
Renewables are not reliable power for us
if you look at
again this sheet which I handed out it
it has the their projected uh new power
sources you see 60 win 21 batteries
fifteen percent solar
and
so I as as I indicated virtually all is
renewable based the massive batteries
currently do not exist and if they
existed would only Supply four hours of
power
iso's 2050 study says fossil fuel units
will be necessary for energy balance
meaning that if we're going to have
reliable power we have to build twice we
got to build Renewables and then we have
to build a reliable fossil fuel
source to Supply Power
pass between North and South New England
would need significant upgrades to
transfer Surplus generation in Northern
New England to generation in Southern
New England
meaning although mass and Connecticut
have large wind and solar projects they
they will be inadequate or as noted drop
off before construction as ISO has
pointed out in their in their
presentation to us last week
so they will look to Northern New
England to fill the void
what we're seeing is cost shifting from
those states that are heavily relying on
building out Renewables
from Mass Connecticut Rhode Island to
the rate payers of New Hampshire again
going back to my very first point why
did I propose this study
because costs are going out of control
so I uh earnestly request your attention
to at least study the prospect of
whether New Hampshire has advantages
or as well as disadvantages of dropping
out of isil New England and becoming an
independent operator
with that I'm open for questions
I might add that the quotes that I
mentioned about I saw New England's
concerns for the future are found on
page 17 of the presentation they gave us
okay well thank you for that present
excuse me that uh Bill introduction
and representative notter would like to
ask you a question
hi thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question I'm a little
confused so you're gonna have to um
help me out here because ISO New England
we've been there it's like NORAD from
that movie in the 80s
if we're not on that grid then where
will our grid be
it was it would be run out of New
Hampshire so probably the most logical
station would be where eversource
operates out of they they cover most of
uh most of New Hampshire and and they
have all the interconnections with the
other utilities there as well but it
would it would be obviously a cost to
create a New Hampshire owned New
Hampshire operated station
follow-up but would the cost benefit
ratio be in our favor
that's why I asked for the study
commission what are the pros what are
the cons I don't know the answer to that
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question you mentioned a lot
about Seabrook stations I have a couple
of concerns with that
um first of all obviously it doesn't run
all the time so it's a good capacity
factor in the low 90s so it would be out
we'd have to replace that power I assume
uh but you would say it would stay in
New Hampshire right now Seabrook has
contracts with out of state uh uh energy
suppliers uh down in Connecticut for
example would you somehow void those
contracts and make C work only sell
their power in New Hampshire or they'd
be free to sell it wherever they select
fit to see it like they do now
I I'm presuming that would be one of the
issues studied by the commission and I'm
presuming that if they said oh it makes
sense to do this then the legislative
solution would be to create a New
Hampshire focused ISO that said New
Hampshire producers must sell first to
New Hampshire any excess could go out
but I I don't know it's just you know
follow up follow up yeah um have you
looked into what the legal requirements
are I mean it's just I don't think it's
a matter of Simply New Hampshire
announcing to the rest of New England
we're leaving because obviously it has
huge ramifications on the other states
so we're generally an exporter of power
um we put we produce more than we
consume that is so is there any legal
requirements that could Massachusetts
block this would they take us to court
is there what is the commitment that New
Hampshire made to become part of iso New
England and what would be the how would
they get out of that well we're the ISO
structures regulated by the federal
energy energy regulatory commissions
Burke so you know if we be if we wanted
to become independent we're going to
have to comply with with whatever
whatever those laws are and I'm sure our
neighbors
when they see they're going to end up
paying more for their power and their
decisions on how they want their power
generated would sue us yes we are a net
power producer and a net cheaper power
producer
uh representative Kaplan has a question
thanks for taking my question Mr chair
and thank you representative
um this is a similar question in in
terms of the ferc uh any withdrawal that
we or that our utilities decided to do
would have to be approved by the Federal
Energy Regulatory Commission and since
their main interest is ensuring Regional
grid stability of transmission and by
withdrawing from the iso we would be
blowing a big hole in the regional power
system
how do you just two questions how do you
foresee them ever allowing us to leave
and if if they didn't allow us to leave
would the scope of your study commission
include disentangling ourselves from
federal regulations and uh you know of
the entity that we call the United
States
I don't think we're going to disentangle
from the United States
over energy uh what the legal
ramifications are of disentangling from
farker changing jurisdictional
boundaries of of an ISO uh grid area I
those are interesting legal questions
and that's that's why we need a study
commission to do this this is a bigger
question than us just sitting down here
and saying oh the pros and cons of this
are and let's do it we we need a study
commission to evaluate those pros and
cons
follow-up you know I'm assuming you have
a theory of the case of for how this
would lead to any benefits for a New
Hampshire rate payers uh considering
that you know we really don't own
Seabrook or the Schiller Power Station
those are private companies that have to
rent the contracts on their own behalf
and we could unless we seceded from the
United States and nationalize those
those assets we can't tell them what to
do
so how did what is your theory of the
case How would how would we be able to
provide lower rates
for New Hampshire ratepayers given that
you know the administration and the the
regulation and all those all those
Services we would have to provide
ourselves all the power producers in in
the uh in in the region are privately
owned none of the the well there's a few
in Vermont that are publicly owned
because they didn't uh totally sign on
to uh the a a entirely private uh uh
Power production plan but all all states
are that way so
we share
power production between all those
States so if we would become our own
entity then we would share that power
production in New Hampshire and the
other five states which would uh would
share their power production it's just
simply dividing the pie up that way
representative Doug Thomas has a
question
oh thank you Mrs more of a housekeeping
one here uh on on your commission I
noticed you didn't include the consumer
Advocate on here
um I don't think I saw it in all league
is there oh maybe I missed it but on the
four House of Representatives
would use succumb to a suggestion that
at least two of them should be coming
from the uh from the Science and Tech
committee I'm open to that Amendment
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair and thank you for
introducing this bill
um you mentioned that Maine and
Connecticut have done similar
assessments do you know what their
recommendation or what their conclusions
were
they in the end decided not to move
forward and I do not know the full
rationale why
um
neither of them are net power producers
like New Hampshire and that may be one
of the key reasons
they would have to rely on still getting
power from externalities
representative Wendy no
oh sorry thank you
I understood I understood
okay seeing no more questions from the
committee we thank you representative
Bernardi for introducing the bill
and we will now call on Josh Elliott
representing the department of energy
for his testimony on House Bill 443.
welcome back Mr Elliott
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record Josh
Elliott director of the division of
policy and programs the New Hampshire
Department of energy
um I know I pale in comparison to Mr
Roper so I will do my best to fill his
seat while he's uh tied up with other
things today
um so the department is neutral on this
bill um we did want to highlight a
couple of things as a prime sponsor had
mentioned on both Connecticut and Maine
have looked at this through various
studies certainly substantive studies in
Maine's case it was a two-year process
Consultants were engaged Etc so it was a
very thorough process Connecticut went
through a similar that was back in
2007-2008 Connecticut did this a little
bit more recently in the uh in 2020
um did an analysis a little bit on the
shorter side and I can get all these
documents to the committee as well so
they can review them at their Leisure
they're quite large so I didn't bring
copies with me here today
um
in anticipation of some of the questions
at least Connecticut's uh there were
certainly certainly uh legal issues
um whether it's other states would be
suing
um if another state left
um what happens to either Investments
that have been made as sort of a
regional grid
um uh and sort of the recovery as long
as for Investments that are made in
other states for example if you know as
portion of a project that was done in
New Hampshire
um you know Connecticut rate pairs as
being part of Vice New England paid for
a portion of that project
Etc so there's lots of other legal
questions that haven't necessarily been
adjudicated in a court of law or sort of
make their way up whether it's at ferc
whether it's regular a U.S District
Court Etc
um
so I guess there is uh if the committee
does decide to move forward with such a
commission
um to realize that there's certain
limitations again those other two
reports engaged with Consultants it was
a very long process because these are
not uh there's
they're particularly complex issues when
you're dealing with uh with ISO New
England both federal law as well as
things where they're within ferk's
jurisdiction
um so if you decide to move forward
um again that is structured you could
just do sort of a review by the by the
folks who are named here would certainly
be a little bit more limited in scope
um could certainly get opinions from
sort of outside entities as what the
answer may be on some of those things
but you may get conflicting information
just because it's it's not a settled
issue
um
uh with that
uh I am happy to take any questions
committee may have
thank you we appreciate the department
being here to testify on this bill I
have a quick question before I recognize
representative Doug Thomas and that is
you said that Maine had done a study and
it covered a two-year time span and they
required some Consultants
if we were to set up a similar
commission or a commission should there
be an appropriation of of Monies to hire
Consultants would that be in a a
valuable addition to the bill I think if
you really wanted to get to the answers
I believe the prime sponsor is listening
is intending to answer I think that
would probably be the best approach to
get a substantive product at the end
thank you representative Doug Thomas has
a question thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question I'm sure this will be
answered in the course of the commission
if if we if we had one but I'll ask you
should we separate from the grid would
that mean that any
transmission projects that we have would
have to build in in the state would
would be fully paid for by just the
state of New Hampshire
I am not a legal expert but considering
that the only the only rate payer is at
disposal in order to fund those projects
would be New Hampshire rate pairs if it
were a separate ISO
um I would assume yes
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question you mentioned the
main study that took place over two
years can you just briefly give us what
was the conclusion of that study
um so there there are
um it was actually done by the Maine
Public Utilities Commission so gone over
over two years
um I am actually waiting on the hard
copies from the main puc to actually get
him to be able to dig into the study
there are references and news articles
if you're looking around on the internet
to find it
um I think a lot of the discussions were
around the complexities of actually sort
of disentangling um they had two options
to look at whether to set up their own
ISO within Maine or to join with New
Brunswick and the other Maritime
Provinces in a grid so sort of the
discussion was a little bit different so
it was geared a little bit differently
in just in terms of
um you're adding uh an international
Dynamic to the discussion as well
follow-up
follow-up but the conclusion was that it
was not in the best interest of Maine to
go forward with it
I believe that was the conclusion again
I haven't read the full report myself so
I don't want to I don't want to cast it
I don't want to put words in the
report's mouth that aren't actually
there
representative Munn says a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming back today
um when I when I first read this bill
the one word that came to my mind right
away was Texas
and the situation that they had
um a year year and a half ago
um
would do if we were to separate from ISO
would that put us in a similar situation
to Texas where they're entirely reliant
on our own resources and not able to get
power from outside the outside the state
I think the state would benefit from
having the existing infrastructure that
currently exists today and being able to
move power back and forth um whether
it's you're going through another
regulatory entity in between ISO New
England and in theory New Hampshire
um
best to say I don't know I imagine again
I imagine we're not deconstructing any
of the existing infrastructure so we'd
still be able to advance be able to use
that to what extent we would be able to
use it at what cost if we were a
separate
um uh a separate ISO I don't know
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um I'd like some clarification please if
I um if if New Hampshire left the energy
grid and I am an energy generator does
this dictate who I could sell my product
to
I don't believe so because those
generators have existing contracts
either I think someone had mentioned
with Seabrook um having contracts with
Connecticut
um as well as if they have contracts
with other
um either utilities or other entities
for electricity I don't think this would
in any way
avoid them
um again I am not a contracts expert or
an attorney but I I can't imagine that
being in a separate group would void
those contracts in any way
but I I don't know that to be to be
certain follow-up follow-up so does this
mean that that even if we left the grid
I would I could if I chose to I could
still benefit from from the grid
you would still as far as selling my
product Oh and started selling your
product yes if you are a generation in
New Hampshire and you just you know you
decide to bid in for default service out
of a utility in Massachusetts yes you'd
still be able to do that now what those
tariffs look like for using other
infrastructure I don't know because then
it would depend on what ISO New England
would do sort of in response in terms of
power moving back and forth okay thank
you thank you
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um I'm a little surprised to hear that
Doe is neutral on this bill is that
because you actually weighed pros and
cons and just couldn't conclude or is it
that DOA really wishes to not weigh in
um I would say generally speaking when
it comes to study committee committees
and commissions usually the department
doesn't take a position one way or the
other if it's a something that the
legislature wishes to look at um we
don't really think it's the Department's
business to tell you whether or not you
should look at a topic
representative Nutter has a question
thank you this is a follow-up on uh
representative Doug Thomas's question
about paying for transmission costs so
do the other states help us pay for our
transmission costs now or is it the
other way around and have a follow-up
yes um so think of it sort of like the
maybe this isn't the best committee but
the highway fund right if I'm going and
paying for gas here in Concord a portion
of that you know we'll go to pay a reap
repave a road up in Pittsburgh even
though I've never driven on Route 3 in
Pittsburgh yet
um you know my my uh road toll Revenue
goes to help pay for those roads not
just the roads that I in particular use
so it's the same sort of basic concept
however the way that it's allocated
among all of the states
um in terms of if there is a if there's
a large project being done that falls
within those jurisdictions for
Interstate
um
um as part of iso New England is a large
larger transmission project or a larger
reliability project costs are allocated
by a percentage of the state's load in
the New England grid so for example New
Hampshire accounts for roughly between
depending on when you count between nine
and ten percent of the load of all of
New England as a whole
um therefore New Hampshire uh New
Hampshire rate payers share of any of
those large transmission projects come
to eight or nine or excuse me nine or
ten percent of whatever that total
project is follow up follow up so I was
wondering if it was um if it's all fair
and even or is New Hampshire the cash
cow right now for
um ISO New England uh yeah so it's all
it's all based on whatever the
percentage of of electricity usage or
load that is uh excuse me electricity
that is consumed by each of the states
so it's basically you know if we we
account for about 10 of it we're uh we
have to pay in New Hampshire repairs are
responsible for 10 of whatever the cost
is even if it's a project that's in
Connecticut or Rhode Island Vermont or
Maine
thank you okay representative Kaplan has
a question
thank you Mr chair um as somebody who
does strategy planning for for the state
um you mentioned that the transmission
infrastructure at the present seems
pretty uh decent for us and I'm assuming
the generation capacities you would say
the same thing but what about 10 years
down the road you know the fuel mix is
changing the generation mix is changing
the transmission needs will change
wouldn't it be wiser to be able to cast
from a wider net of resources rather
than restrict ourselves to what we can
produce and what we can do in the state
and that's for everything from raising
money to pay for projects to generating
to transmitting to administering to
marketing to procuring wouldn't it be
wiser to rely on a wider Network
trying to think of how to answer that um
as being part of a larger entity there
are certainly uh you know pluses and
minuses of being able to sort of have
those economies of scale that you
mentioned
um certainly ISO New England is looking
at a variety of different things I know
they came and presented a few weeks ago
here
um you know certainly transmission is
one of those things we have a pretty
reliable uh transmission infrastructure
and that's from having made large
Investments over the last 10 or 15 years
into that Network that's probably only
going to grow as we further incorporate
renewable Technologies into the grid
based on they're very site-specific you
can't just drop you know solar panels
anywhere in particular or wind turbines
they have to be you know you have to
want to put them in places where they
have the best capacity factors so with
that you would have the additional
transmission capacity that would be
needed to move that move that generation
Supply to where the demand is
um so I suppose that's a very roundabout
way of not really answering your
question but
okay seeing no further questions I want
to thank you for your testimony here
this afternoon we appreciate it thank
you very much Mr chairman
all right we'll now move to the last
person who has signed up to testify and
I'll alert anybody sitting out there
that if you want to testify I need to
see a pink card from you please
but uh in any case right now we will
hear from Mr William Hall who's from
Durham welcome Bill Hall
thank you chairman boss
um I saw this and it kind of scared me
now I'll tell you why
we recently had a proposal here before
it's been discussed this year where they
wanted to Outsource emissions
legislation to California bypassing the
missions uh for chain bypassing the
legislative processes here when changes
happen in California I wasn't very
impressed with that
the New Hampshire house
chose to bankrupt the power company
to stop Seabrook
when you have the people that want to do
that sort of thing that cost the
stockholders the rate payers the rate
payers over two two thousand dollars a
person a couple of million bucks uh just
so that you can play Jane Fonda and stop
a nuke plant they stopped one but they
didn't stop the other so when you have
Mischief Mischief people like that in
your system I I get very nervous
um
we had a proposal to bring down clean
Hydro transmission electrical
transmission from Canada
that was opposed by one of the parties
and one of the candidates for Governor
was this and it's got was stopped I know
that uh a confirm in Boston that was
hired to evaluate the uh what it would
do to the property values their initial
report said nothing and all of a sudden
the contract was unfunded and died
um
more Healy in our ads said that she'd
stop two pipelines okay that's why
electricity cost us 30 cents a kilowatt
now
that's one of the reasons
our delegation to Washington didn't
choose to back up our governor what
whoops I forgot to press my button if I
could just interrupt you for a second we
don't typically name individuals oh
sorry in this committee one we I'm sorry
entertain testimony all right our
delegation to Washington uh chose not to
back our governor and the other five
governors in New England to
um uh in their letter from last July
saying how we could avoid this price
increase and what we had to do and do it
quickly
um
the uh subsequent letter from from uh
the Energy Secretary uh said we're on
our own and uh uh then uh the head of
eversource for New England wrote a very
good letter with a number of bullet
items on it about what we could do to
keep our power our costs down and uh
once again
um that letter has not been supported in
my opinion uh politically uh other than
uh the governor uh as to
um
uh trying to implement those things are
I don't know if you've seen it but if
you haven't seen that letter it's three
pages and half a page of circulation
um
the the only way that we're going to
move forward and have clean Renewable
Power is uh with either Hydro or nuclear
and at the rate we're going uh we're not
going to get another nuclear plant we've
got a hundred nuclear plants that are
going to go offline in the next few
years and this country needs about 200
so we should start building them right
away I'm opposed to this because I I
think that there are other things we
could be doing that would be far more
productive thank you okay thank you very
much any questions for Mr Hall
saying none thank you for being here and
thank you for your testimony
is there anyone in the
assembled audience that would like to
speak to this bill
apparently not looks like I have
badly underestimated the amount of
reaction that this would Bill generate I
expected we'd hear something from the
utilities but apparently not
so we now find ourselves with a lot of
time to kill
between now and the time of the next
public hearing at three o'clock
so it looks like we're going to get some
unexpected vacation time and uh
so with that I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 443
and ask Tom closure to tell us what the
blue sheet recommendations are
thank you on House Bill 443 the blue
sheet was one in favor
Two Against
on line four in favor
44 against
okay thank you very much
so I guess you'll have to entertain
yourselves for the next 55 minutes and
we'll see you back here at three o'clock
I'm sorry for the delay
but it is now three o'clock according to
my whiz-bang device here
so I'm going to open the public hearing
on House Bill 630
establishing a revolving clean energy
accelerator Fund in the department of
energy and called the prime sponsor of
the build representative Rebecca
McWilliams to introduce the bill
representative McWilliams
yeah
we just introduced you representative
the floor is yours
while Ms McWilliams is getting ready
I'll remind everyone here that if you
want to
talk about this bill to the committee we
ask that you fill out a pink card and
submit it to us as soon as possible
thank you very much
and with that representative McWilliams
is now ready and we'll introduce this
legislation
thank you chair Bose colleagues on the
science technology and energy committee
for the record my name is Rebecca
McWilliams I'm a state rep for South
Concord Wards 5678 it's my pleasure to
join you it's been a pleasure to be with
you all day today
so let's talk about the big numbers
the big number
27 billion B 27 billion dollars
committed by the Fed
so those are our tax dollars that went
from New Hampshire and all the tax
dollars from everyone else and all the
states paying taxes to the fed and we
sure would like to get some of that 27
billion back here in order to do good
things with it so
let me pull up
a little bit more about what's going on
um
all right so this bill um House Bill 630
is a revolving energy fund also known as
a green Bank the terms are used somewhat
interchangeably so when I say green Bank
I'm also saying uh revolving clean
energy fund just to be very clear
because the funding from the FED is
specific to Green Banks and that's what
we're trying to do with this bill
currently there are 23 Green Banks in
the United States although more are
being created these are all members of
the American Green Bank Consortium
um it's a program of the Coalition for
green Capital which creates and supports
Green Banks leading to charge and create
a national green Bank Green Banks have
mobilized 9 billion with a B dollars in
overall green investment over the past
10 years using only 2 billion in public
funds so you're seeing that's a
significant return on investment you
start with 2 billion and you turn it
into 9 billion in terms of projects
completed
um Green Banks are mission driven
so despite the name Bank in the title
Green Bank they don't take deposits so
you can't decide to get a debit card and
create a checking account and join the
green Bank as an individual they
function like loan or investment funds
so they use all kinds of financial tools
they differ in governance from state to
state some are fully public some are
quasi-public right PPP public private
partnership we really like doing those
around here and some are fully
independent with no government oversight
or ties to the state so the goal of
green bank is to be financially
sustainable but they're not about
maximizing profit they are mission
driven
um so how does the IRA support Green
Banks we're talking about the inflation
reduction act all that Federal money 27
billion dollars they've made two buckets
the first bucket
is a grant program for the greenhouse
gas reduction fund ghgrf that allocates
27 billion to the EPA to make grants
7 billion this is the small bucket
is accessible directly to cities and
states so your municipality or the state
of New Hampshire can provide financial
support support to do zero emissions
Technologies to low-income and
disadvantaged areas
then 20 billion big bucket
is accessible to non-profit entities
that have the qualities of a green bank
which um obviously the inflation
reduction act has a lot of checklist
criteria on that
um so recipients of the 20 billion must
engage in both direct investment in
projects and indirect investment in
state and local institutions that are
doing Mission aligned work at the state
local and National levels
um so really what I've created in this
legislation is a vehicle to receive
funding in the form of monies from the
FED as part of the inflation reduction
act you're going to hear from people
after me who have very specific nuances
they'd like to change with this bill I
am completely open to amending this bill
to make it work for our state my goal is
to make sure that this money comes back
to New Hampshire and that we don't allow
it to go to some other state instead we
lose the monies that New Hampshire
taxpayers have given to the fed and so
we don't get them back my goal here is
to create that vessel to receive the
money
um and so certainly if we need to talk
about hosting it in a different agency
or Department that's not the department
of energy I'm open to that
if we need to talk about specific
Financial vehicles for how this works
with our local banking institutions I'm
open to that and if we need to talk
about specific targets and goals that
the state would like to have to earmark
the funds in regards to what the FED
wants us to do and what we as a state
want to do in terms of our long-term
planning I'm open to that as well so
really this is this is a
present wrapped up and it's going to get
lots of money in it if we can figure out
how to work together and make it work
for the state so I'm happy to take
questions about this and I know there
are quite a few other folks who'd like
to testify after me
okay thank you representative Mick
Williams for introducing this bill
representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so
um
I'm sure others may be able to explain
this later on but I'm a little bit
confused am I to understand that this
bill
basically just says
let's establish a bank
without any
limits rules any Mission any degree of
Direction uh
you're basically saying let's let's do
something let's put it into law and then
let's decide what to do with it that
that's that's kind of what I'm hearing
when you say that you're open to that
this is open to anything you want to do
with it I'm I'm I'm kind of confused
about that can you expand on that thank
you representative Doug Thomas I'm sorry
if you're confused let me tone it back a
little bit because I get so excited
about getting money back for New
Hampshire this is exciting to me
let's say that within the criteria of
the inflation reduction act there are
certain check boxes that we must check
in order to receive the funds right no
federal funds come without strings
attached
so if we can check the boxes then we
still have latitude as a state to have
priorities and determine exactly how the
money is spent that probably could be
part of legislation but also if we are
setting this up as a revolving fund our
priorities as legislators can be much
more General they they don't have to be
super specific if we choose not to do
that so when I speak in Broad terms what
I'm saying is we can give a high level
Direction and then allow the
implementing agency or authority to
decide exactly how that plays out over
the years with the fund because there
will be changes obviously we've seen
technology is changing every year
so really the goal here is to create a
bucket to receive funds that meet the
check boxes of the FED while still
allowing New Hampshire to make up our
mind about what our priorities are
within the constraints of the program
thank you if you had led with that that
would much work
much more easier to know thank you
you're welcome
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh so
representative McWilliams can you
explain why we have to set up a separate
new entity of whatever flavor wherever
it's going to go why can't any
monies for discrete defined purposes be
deposited in an established financial
institution that has all the appropriate
controls and structure already why can't
we use a regular Bank a regular savings
loan or whatever
so to be clear the term Green
quote-unquote Bank is not really a bank
it's an administered Loan Fund so
there's there's a slight difference in
how it actually comes to play in action
we do have some non-profits capable of
administering funds for loans here in
New Hampshire who could potentially be
the host for a program like this so I'm
kind of trying to come across as
agnostic as to who administers but it
still needs to meet the check boxes
required by the Fed
so it's it's not the kind of bank that
you and I can put our money in and
expect a return on investment it's the
kind of bank that receives money from
the fed and administers loans across the
entire state for specific projects
for a follow-up follow-up so to be clear
a regular Bank a regular savings and a
loan a regular Credit Union does not
have the capability of taking on this
function
so I'm hesitant to say no to your
question representative Bernardi because
I think there may be a way to work that
out but I'm not the person with that
level of knowledge right now to be able
to give you an exact answer I think you
probably want to save that question for
someone after me
all right thank you
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
thinking my question and actually come
explain this pretty well I understand
the uh from what I understand where it
says the department shall administer I'm
guessing I'm the way I take it you're
talking about the department of energy
is going to administrate it and um I
guess the main question I have is the
divvying up of funds you have a bunch of
different projects listed here
um is it spread out evenly equally among
every each one of these how do you
define who gets what and is it
completely up to the department energy
of somebody gets all of it or none of it
or such
um so there are strings attached from
the FED in terms of who gets what money
but I don't have the nuances to exactly
how the split is split out I will tell
you with full disclosure that this bill
is borrowed from the state of Maine and
so that was sort of a first blush first
draft here's an idea for how it could be
split out but New Hampshire doesn't have
to do exactly what Maine did
follow up
thank you and also if uh if a new
project wants to be added or if one
needs more money well there need to be a
ask for an increase for more funding for
one of these projects
so once again that's sort of an
administrative question and I'm so glad
you're asking this representative
Summers usually the way this happens is
with a grant you are awarded a grant
based on your competitive application
and you just get those funds in that
bucket so coming back and asking for a
second wave generally doesn't happen
obviously if it's a super huge project
and you've got all kinds of media
attention and it's the sort of project
that most of us in this room might want
to see happen
sometimes you find a way to find some
more funds but I would say generally for
the projects that we're discussing that
these funds could be used for it's a
one-time application with grant funding
for that project it's a loan and it is
paid back so that future applicants can
then get a loan the next year and the
following year
okay I have a couple of questions before
I go to representative Wendy Thomas
on page three line ten
the proposed legislation talks about
driving Capital into Market gaps
for goods and services can you define
what those Market gaps are
just one second let me catch up with you
page 3 line 10.
okay here we go
clean energy accelerative fund is hereby
established as a dedicated specialized
Finance program designed to drive
private Capital into Market gaps for
goods and services producing lower zero
greenhouse gas emissions and use Finance
tools to mitigate climate change that is
funded by government public private or
charitable contributions invest in our
finances projects alone or in
conjunction with other investors so
Market gaps right now I would say we've
had quite a bit of discussion in this
group about EV charging stations I would
consider that right now to be something
that New Hampshire is lagging in and
could potentially be seen as a market
Gap just right for some kind of outside
capital
okay thank you as a follow-up I would
ask on line 15 of the same page
three line 15 it talks about the rapid
deployment of mature Technologies
would that include nuclear technologies
I don't see why it wouldn't but I'd have
to look at the Ira's criteria I don't
have a no off the top of my head but I
would say nuclear is a mature technology
and so potentially funds could be
directed to that as long as the IRA
doesn't say no
okay thank you and then if you flip over
to page four line one
talks about private private Capital
markets with respect to investing in
greenhouse gas reduction projects
are those the only kind of projects that
these funds could uh be used for its
greenhouse gas reduction projects
so once again we're talking about
receiving federal funds with strings
attached so there is quite a bit of
greenhouse gas reduction language in the
ghgrf from the IRA
um I guess I would have to hear exactly
what you're considering that might be a
project worthy of funding through this
renewable fund that doesn't include some
kind of greenhouse gas reduction
okay so basically your answer is federal
fund strings attached okay I think so
from their ghgrf all right thank you
that's good representative Wendy Thomas
has a question thank you um just a point
of clarification you mentioned
commercial and municipalities having
access to these funds anything for
residential
so representative Wendy Thomas can you
just clarify I'm sorry when you say
anything for residential do you mean
someone who manages many units or do you
mean an individual homeowner
I would think more of a multi-family
multiple units
so but that would be considered
commercial right yes but so this isn't
down to the nuclear level of residential
this is not this is a much higher level
so if the municipality were to take on
some kind of a um
large project that's Energy Efficiency
or solar for rooftops or whatever that
municipality designs decides to sign up
for to use the funds it could be
funneled towards single-family or
multi-unit residential from my reading
but I also don't think it's really
intended to just benefit individual
homeowners okay and I have a follow-up
follow-up
um so if this vehicle is not set up to
receive this money do we lose the money
that's a great question
it will be very difficult for
um
a different entity to step up without
the state's backing
um
so my understanding is that states that
have green Banks can influence the
decisions as to how the money is made
because the state is part of that
states without Green Banks defer
responsibility for administering the
funds to non-profit and not-for-profit
financing institutions so it is still
possible
but in terms of actually having someone
in the room where it happens I think we
want New Hampshire to be involved thank
you
representative Harrington has a question
yeah thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh we're getting back
to nuclear we do terms there it was
mature technology now obviously we have
mature Technologies in nucleus such as
you know sea workstation which has been
operating for a long time but I don't
know of anybody who's planning on even
remotely looking into building something
like that again so would this cover the
new maybe not so Monsieur nuclear
technology such as smrs with small
modular reactors which are more than
likely going to be what the first the
next generation of nuclear reactors
would be they're going to be different
than the standard light water reactors
so would they be covered because they're
not so mature
representative Harrington I think that's
an excellent question I would probably
defer to federal guidelines to answer it
but I'm hopeful because I do think that
that is the wave of nuclear future and
we have some potential in Seabrook for
that
representative Jack has a question uh
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you uh
are you aware of any other situation
where the federal government grants
monies in this quantity to a Commercial
Bank to administer as opposed to a state
uh representative Jack I'm not aware of
it that doesn't mean it doesn't exist
I'm just not aware of it
okay so you know further questions from
the committee I think representative
McWilliams
whoops I guess there was one more well
laid hand
delay a delayed request that's a pretty
big question sure representative partial
has a question yes um I keep on hearing
this referred to as a green Bank
understanding of the doe refers to was
much but in fact it's more of a
dedicated
excitator fund that would sit inside of
the Department of energy for them to
administer
is that about is that
thank you for the clarification
questions that's what I could clarify
um so I started out this presentation by
saying I'm open to it being hosted in a
different department if Department of
energy doesn't feel that numbers and
math and specifically money is their
thing that's okay we have other state
authorities who may be a better match
but certainly that's the intention as it
was drafted based on the main model
thank you that's
okay
so would you be open to a potential
Amendment to the bill that
opens it up to for example the um
the New Hampshire
there isn't there is another revolving
Loan Fund administrator within New
Hampshire government I've forgotten the
name of the department that administers
it right now yes okay all right thank
you thank you all right so you know
other questions from the committee we'll
thank representative McMillan McWilliams
for introducing this bill and next I
will call to the
testimony table
Mr Josh Elliott from the Department of
energy
uh good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record Josh
Elliott director of the division of
policy and programs the New Hampshire
Department of energy uh the department
is neutral on this bill um I think
representative McWilliams laid out a
good presentation in terms of the source
of funds the IRA administered by the EPA
um that make these funds available on a
competitive basis so New Hampshire or
whatever entity the community decides
should be the best entity to receive
these funds would have to file an
application there's no guarantee that
funds are would be
awarded to the state obviously depends
on the the value of the application that
is submitted so just want to make sure
that clear remembering back to my
presentation talking about formula
grants versus competitive this would
fall into the competitive category
um the department just uh again we're
neutral if the committee decides we're
the best agency to run these funds you
know you know you tell us to jump we ask
how high
um just a couple of things for
consideration as as uh if you decide to
move forward this bill in its current
form
um I will note
um
on page four lines 25 to 26 where it
goes through uh talks about any
sustaining operations shall manage the
department shall manage revenue from
financing fees interest repaid loans and
other types of funding
um
just would want to make it clear that
the if awarded These funds that the
department could pay for staff up front
before the loans were actually
administered it's probably enough of a
stretch from a legal standpoint to say
that other funds would count but just to
make it clear that the department could
actually
um
pay for folks before loan repayments
start coming back in into the fund
um
there is a question and I don't know and
again the the bill is written broadly
enough that I don't know if this would
come up but on the off chance EPA is
currently going through their uh process
to come up with the guidelines for how
these funds will be administered I
believe they're still in the What's
called the RFI phase or request for
information essentially they're seeking
input from other entities whether it's
other states whether it's other
stakeholders sort of in the process
existing Green Banks about what these
funds should look like what the process
should look like what the applications
should look like what they should be
considered when they're looking at
awarding funds
um
so if the state is more strict than
whatever those guidelines come from the
federal government then there's really
no issue on implementation but if for
some reason the EPA says uh we must do X
or we must allow this sort of you know
uh uh projects are eligible and the
state law is structured in such a way
that it doesn't allow us to do that
there's a question about okay if we the
the federal government who is mandate
you know who basically tells us what we
can and can't do with these funds is
saying You must do this and state law is
saying well you can't do that just if
there's some mechanism there and again I
don't know there's nothing obvious in
the Bill of where I could say oh that's
probably going to be an issue with this
particular provision but
just in general something to think about
of to make sure if there's some sort of
conflict though that is dealt with um
just to make sure the department isn't
hamstrung of trying to figure out do we
violate federal law or state law
um
uh back on
um page four uh Roman eight
um so it's lines uh 22
um
oh excuse me I'm sorry uh Romans 7
excuse me line 16 through 21 where it
has the following provision shall govern
the funds project prioritization
requirements and let's talk about a
which has the mitigation the reduction
of greenhouse gas emissions and then B
which is the
um
requirement that 40 of the investment
activity directed to serve vulnerable
communities which is defined elsewhere
in the bill
additional direction would be helpful
um just in terms of what happens if
we're in a situation of where the
apartment is seeing sort of a batch of
loans come in for projects one that
would dramatically reduce greenhouse gas
emissions however
um you know you could make an argument
that the benefits largely accrue to
communities that don't fit the profile
of the 40 percent or if we're looking at
a bunch of uh of projects asking for
financing that meet all the the 40
percent
um I'm sorry they're all targeted
towards uh vulnerable communities but
the greenhouse gas emissions that would
be realized from such a project are less
than those that would be in a
non-vulnerable community
um so just a sense of balance of how you
look wanted a department to take a look
at those balancing those two priorities
if for some reason there's a conflict
um
I read that section is to mean rather
than sort of a year by year basis it is
a sort of over the
um you know the administration of a fund
for sort of the duration that you try to
match to make sure that there's
um that you hit that 40 percent but it
would be not in any particular given
year it must be 40 percent
um so again just for consideration for
additional legislative Direction on that
would be
um helpful the last piece
um
what did I know there was some
discussion about this earlier
um I don't see any provision in here for
whatever reason
um that if the state were to apply for
these funds and say rather than you know
out of the 27 billion for example they
decide okay New Hampshire you're going
to get a million dollars
to you know to have to hire staff to
administer a revolving Loan Fund of just
a million dollars I know it's a big
number but in terms of state agencies
there's not a lot of money to be
managing it would make more sense on
that basis to contract that out with a
third party
um whether it's for example we have a
couple of of small funds that we have uh
contracts with the Community Development
Finance Authority or the cdfa who
manages those on a revolving loan basis
that would be um similar to these
projects here but at a million dollars
for example
um you know it would make more sense for
the Department to go out and contract
with some other entity such as again
Community Development Finance Authority
or the perhaps the business Finance
Authority
um depending on um which entity was
probably better suited and again with
the Department would go through the
regular RFP process to determine what
kind of entity would be the the best one
to receive a um those State funds
um so those were really the the only
things just in terms of purely the
administration uh administrative portion
of okay how does the department actually
act on these if if we get the funds just
to make sure you know there are plenty
of times just in on the programmatic
side of uh where clear legislative
Direction rather than letting the
department try to figure out okay well
what did the legislature mean by this
and do they really mean that or should
we do this so I always appreciate clear
legislative Direction when it comes up
to these issues so with that I will stop
talking and Mr chairman I'm happy to
take questions
thank you very much some very good
suggestions uh and reactions to this
bill we appreciate that representative
Corman has a question for you thank you
Mr chair and thank you Mr Elliott uh
when you talked about page four lines 25
and 26 I'm afraid I just didn't really
understand what you were telling us can
you clarify that please oh sure
um so on lines 25 and 26 um so it's
under Roman 8 which starts on page I'm
sorry line 22 which is the provisions
that govern the administration of the
fund um so really that uh section
subsection B there lines 25 and 26 to
sustain operations the gov the
department shall manage Revenue oh I
excuse me I'm sorry
um
where am I looking here
oh I'm sorry yes to sustain operations
the department shall manage revenue from
financing fees interest repaid loans and
other types of funding
um so essentially
um I would just uh I should say not I
personally but other department would
wish to see clear language that would
allow the funding of staff from the
original capitalization from the fund um
because that would give us the staff in
order to actually do the initial round
of of of loan Awards and and especially
depending on the terms of the loans
um those repayments may not be coming in
immediately so there would be some lag
time before Revenue was received back
into the fund so just want to make it
clear that the
um
Department could could use some of those
funds up front to pay for staff to set
up the program
thank you thank you representative munz
has a question thank you Mr chair and
thank you again for being here
um I want to follow up on a question
that representative Bernardi asked the
previous uh asked representative
McWilliams when she introduced the bill
um concerning whether or not this money
could be given to a private financial
institution
um I'm assuming and I don't know if you
can comment on this but I'm assuming
that that would not be possible because
the federal government would not would
not allow that that one of the
provisions of the program is that it has
to go to a state agency
so it doesn't necessarily so usually how
I'm sorry thank you for the question
generally speaking
um a lot of these programs whether it's
this one or other ones there are
um uh what they called eligible entities
who are allowed to apply
um for these funds
um I'm trying to recall off the top of
my head I don't believe private Banks or
other sort of Institutions are listed as
eligible entities it's usually state
agencies existing Green Banks
um I believe there's a provision for
certain non-profits so in this case it
would be organizations like Community
excuse me Community Development Finance
Authority or the business Finance
Authority
um or set of other entities that like
that
um again I'm trying to recall off the
top of my head but I don't believe
private entities sort of like a bank or
uh or some other entity would be
eligible
follow-up
um so you you mentioned the community
Finance Development Authority I'm a
little bit familiar with that
organization
um could they administer this type of
program or would there have to be some
change in their Charter
I don't want to thank you for the
question I don't want to speak on behalf
of the Community Development Finance
Authority or are there sort of similar
organizations I
don't believe there would be any
restriction but again I don't know the
the terms that govern their organization
thank you
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um getting back to uh the middle of uh
page four there on Section seven so it
gives me line 18. it talks about
the department shall maximize the
reduction of greenhouse gas emissions in
the state for every dollar deployed by
the fund that seems to me to be an
absolute statement that would be
difficult to comply with because as soon
as you come up with one idea that says
these of all the ideas we see this will
give us the maximum uh reduction in
greenhouse gases someone can come up
with another one says oh no this one
will do a little bit more so shouldn't
the words be shells something like shall
strive to maximize or shall you know
something on that idea rather than
making it absolute because I don't see
how the Department's going to be able to
deal with an absolute like that without
being challenged constantly
um thank you for the question I I read
that provision
um as so for example if um
I should say I read that as a sort of
directive when the department is scoring
or evaluating different proposals that
come into it of that sort of of the
primary you know the factor in scoring
these um applications for a lack of a
better way of describing them for
financing that they would have they
would have to be some Metric as part of
our application process that would say
okay how much how many
um how much greenhouse gas emissions are
you reducing so do we do you know do you
have to go through the process of
figuring out okay which ones are we just
talking about carbon dioxide are we
doing it other types of greenhouse gases
such as methane things like that and you
know how does this project propose to
reduce those and by how much so there
would certainly be some work by the
department to try to come up with a
an objective metric in terms of of
having the applicant describe what kind
of how much they're avoiding or how much
they're preventing from being released
um but to your point there yes somebody
could argue well you know the
Department's method of of evaluating
this or saying you know using this
Factor versus that factor uh could
certainly be contested by applicants
um I don't
um I'm not sure of an of an elegant way
around that other than specifying
well and
now I couldn't I guess you couldn't even
specify you couldn't even specify a
number in statute and say Here's you
know nothing below this amount it has to
be better than this then you know then
it would be funded but
what my concern is they is not that you
won't have a method I understand you'll
have to come up with some measuring uh
device or whatever you want to cut
criteria to decide okay this is how
we're going to we're going to drop it
into this bucket and turn the handle and
it'll come out with a score my concern
is that when you say you shall maximize
you do that and you come up with you
have 10 projects and you pick one and
then the next day someone says well
here's another one you didn't consider
this you're not maximizing it because
this one will get more I just think the
me the words may be too absolute is what
I'm referring to it needs to be
something more like we'll strive to
maximize or to the extent possible or
something like that as a modifier so you
don't get hung up with someone that
ended up taking it to court on something
like that that's all okay no thank you
for the clarification I had sort of
envisioned this as either an annual
round or maybe a semi-annual around
where where entities come in and apply
and you'd have sort of a set but right
if it's a rolling application then you
could say have somebody come in the next
day you know with a different Apple
application that had it been in the the
you know the day before with that group
of applications you know might have
knocked somebody else out from getting
funded right to your point yes
but it would all depend on how the how
the program is structured but thank you
that is that is important thing to
consider representative Summers has a
question
thank you Mr chairman uh just a quick
question I know I'm looking at this bill
and I know it was submitted and printed
before there's a fiscal note available
so the physical note might cover this
but I'm looking at this and seeing all
these multiple tasks that the if you
guys if Department of energy was
administrating it you have many many
tasks here to go through all these shell
assignments that you all should do do
you have any idea what kind of Staffing
costs requirements what department of
energy would need to accomplish this
thank you for the question
um yes it would depend honestly it
depends on what the uh the amount of the
capitalization for the type of program
would be if it's a lower amount
um and with additional language we could
potentially go out and contract for some
of these services for the
um for the general administration of the
funds for example making the loans
vetting potential
applicants for you know Financial
their financial their credit worthiness
or things like that
um as well as for the actual uh you know
the um
uh the the strength of the application
on their on their merits
um there's certainly comply certainly a
compliance piece the department does
this as well we have a compliance
officer who looks at our other federal
funds that makes sure you know we're in
compliance with all the various
um Federal Pro Federal requirements so
is build America Davis bacon things like
that um we again Davis bacon is probably
the best example or prevailing wages
um of where
um we may we if depending on the size of
the fund we may have a dedicated person
who would be hired to just keep track of
those things but
um so I apologize for the long-winded
answer but it would honestly it all
comes down to you know are we talking
about a one million dollar fund are we
talking about a 10 million dollar fund
50 million dollars so it would staff
would have to scale depending on the
size
so I apologize for the non-answer answer
okay representative Harrington thought
of another question yeah just a
follow-up to that uh regardless of how
it's done does the federal money pay for
whether it's additional staff or we have
you contracted out can we use that money
to pay for the service to to run this
program or does that have to be State
funds
um generally speaking and again it will
determine it will be determined by all
of the federal guidance that comes out
surrounding these programs generally
speaking I don't think I've seen a
single federal program where they've
said no the state needs to kick in for
the uh administrative costs usually
there's a portion
um of the uh of any federal allocation
that is a lot better allowed for
administrative expenses so whether it's
on administrative expenses on the part
of the department or on a sub grantee
um there are usually Provisions that
allow for that follow-up follow-up I
just we that's a key point we obviously
have to know the answer to that question
before we vote on this bill so I can I
can do some further research and get an
answer for you thank you representative
partial has a question
thank you chair Wells and thank you for
being here today
um page three line 35 speaks of
partnering with private Capital
providers and capital markets to attract
co-investment from private Banks goes on
page four line 30 says the department
May accept and use philanthropic funds
and looking for the best fit for a
program of this nature
do you think the uh
Department of energy will be capable of
seeking out these private and
philanthropic funds
okay
yeah
it's sort of a unique space where I
don't know if I you know another state
agency would be a better fit Des does
revolving loan funds but they just there
for water and sewer uh or clean water
grants I should say
um but those really don't leverage a lot
of private funds it's all you know
either Municipal funds or if it's State
dollars going into these funds
um I had uh
in terms of private you know if if the
department were tasks are doing this I'm
certainly I'm sure that we would hire
the right staff to make sure that we're
going out and doing all of these kinds
of things part of it may just be a
um a requirement on the applicant's part
of where they're showing okay you're
coming in for a loan for maybe three
quarters of the cost or half the cost or
something like that but they've said
okay we've gone out to our bank and
they're willing to put up some money or
they've gotten a grant from you know in
New Hampshire maybe it's
um you know Northern borders Regional
Commission they're doing a project
they've managed to get a grant for that
so
um
and then we sort of talk about you know
skin of the game right there have
there's something else that's going on
they're sort of putting together These
funds that you know a lot of projects in
New Hampshire are sort of based off of
where I get a little bit from here a
little bit here from a little bit from
here
um so I sort of viewed that as sort of
doing that
um but certainly as some of the project
like because this is is stood up and
works its way out and it becomes more
mature you know private Capital I'm
assuming would would come in and other
um entities although it's a little bit
hard when you're dealing with just
purely alone program of where
um folks will come in and say well it's
like oh well you know I would like a you
know alone 100 from you rather than
trying to find you know alone here alone
here and alone here and then that the
financing gets a little bit messy and
you're dealing with different terms and
conditions and things like that I will
say with federal funds as soon as a
dollar federal funds goes into a project
all the other strings come along with it
um so there is sort of a of a um
reluctance on the part of of some uh
financial institutions for
um being part not necessarily being
Partners in projects when it comes to
federal funds but having all those other
strings attached sort of when if the
bank had just made the loan to another
entity 100 they don't need to worry
about all those compliance concerns
thank you thank you very much
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair when a a similar Bill to
this was introduced I think it was last
session there were some concerns raised
about
um language in that bill that might
um
be discriminatory in terms of
discriminating against certain in favor
of certain people or against certain
people groups of people is there
anything in this bill that that concerns
you from that point of view is there
anything that you would consider
discriminatory
thank you
I hadn't taken a read of it in that
using that sort of lens but nothing off
the top of my head looks that way
um in reading through
um I to to the to your question I don't
know what the specific
charge was that potentially could
potentially be discriminatory so I guess
I'm not sure how to answer that question
without without knowing that
it's very representative Wendy Thomas
has a question thank you Mr chair
um we currently have a water fund that's
similar it's a bunch of money and a
committee
allocates loans and grants based on
applications do you see this as being
committee driven to make the decisions
on applications or would the decisions
be solely made by the DOE
um so I'm glad you brought that up so
I'm assuming you're referring to the
drinking water groundwater trust fund
advisory commission so I'm actually a
member of that commission so
um I work with Senator Morris to set it
up when I worked for the Senate and then
when I left and came over to doe they
wanted to keep me around so I got an
appointment to it
um honestly it could go either way
um if the if it will the legislatures to
set up sort of a similar Commission of
where you have sort of a broad range of
folks who are evaluating these
applications I will say as a member of
the commission we rely heavily on the
Department of Environmental Services for
in terms of sort of either the history
around the around the project or other
things that we may not be considering
because I will say I'm I'm not an expert
on all the engineering that goes into
various water projects or sort of the
stories that come along with some of
them other than what's in the
application in front of me
um that being said that sort of
structure I found is very unique in
terms of state government where there's
not a lot of other state agencies that
have sort of Advisory Board telling them
how to spend their their money
um that being said I don't I wouldn't I
don't think the department would have a
strong opinion one way or the other on
it but being a member of the commission
I certainly
um I view it as useful but not
necessarily a requirement uh follow-up
follow up thank you um you mentioned uh
Department of Environmental Services
would you be working in conjunction with
Des for this for this project oh there
we go speak the devil
um I guess the answer you must have
heard you
um certainly you know we would be we'd
be working with other uh certainly with
with other state agencies
um you know Des has a lot of valuable
experience when it comes to revolving
loan funds in terms of structuring um
sort of the mechanics behind that I know
Sue Carlson is certainly an expert on
those things we would certainly relying
on on that knowledge but
um you know in terms of sort of an
evaluation committee when it comes to
reducing you know greenhouse gas
emissions you know it certainly would we
would be collaborative in talking to our
folk to our friends over at DES
um
and I'm sure they would appreciate
hearing from us as well thank you thank
you very much not to put them on the
spot
thank you
okay seeing no further questions
representative Jack has a question thank
you Mr chairman uh thank you for
bringing up the srfs I was trying to
figure out how to get that in there in
the form of a question wouldn't you
agree with me that the the
administration of the this is the clean
and Wastewater estate resolve revolving
loan funds that come to our committee uh
Public Works committee wouldn't you
agree that that this is their sort of a
worked example for how this could work
uh yes I think they would probably they
would provide a valuable example of of
using federal dollars and using them as
a large revolving Loan Fund within state
government
thank you just as a reminder to
or as a point of information for
visitors to our committee we do not
permit would you believe or do you agree
with me kind of questions my apologies
Mr chairman not that's not your fault
okay
all right seeing no further questions
for Mr Elliott we want to thank you for
providing the Department's perspective
on this proposed legislation thank you
very much Mr chairman thank you and I'd
like to call the final speaker for this
bill that's Sam Evans Brown from clean
energy New Hampshire
welcome Sam good to see you again
I have some written testimony they could
submit but actually many of the points
have been addressed already so I'll I'll
hold off until uh uh speaking my name is
Sam Evans Brown I'm the executive
director of clean energy New Hampshire
um I would just like to say put a uh uh
put a emphasis on two points here one is
just the quantity of dollars that we're
talking about which I think there's the
potential that if uh if I'm doing my
math right we might be talking more than
tens of millions of dollars that could
flow into the state through this through
this fund so if we look at the formula
grants that the state is eligible for
that just come to the state uh
automatically as long as they submit a
submit a proposal that meets with
federal guidelines uh thinking of the
the homes program and the HERO program
which are both part of the inflation
reduction act those together and Josh
can correct me from the back of the room
I think are in the 70 million dollar
range and that that larger pot of money
did I get a thumbs up from Josh yeah
okay right uh and that larger pot of
money is around nine billion dollars and
so when we're talking about a pot of
money that's 20 billion dollars
um you can think roughly double uh might
be available to each state and then if
you consider that this is a competitive
Grant process and some states will not
be awarded funds we might be talking
about even more and so in preparation
for this hearing I've been reaching out
to a number of uh non-profits and other
entities that might be eligible for this
type of funding the the business Finance
Authority I think is one that leaps to
mind we've talked about the community
developments Finance Authority already
uh the Community Loan Fund is one that I
thought of and I will confess that my
organization actually responded to the
the RFI that the federal government put
out in December uh because it might even
be that my organization might be
eligible for some of this funding
um and all this is to say that that I
think the the quantity of money
available and the uncertainty as to as
to uh who can apply for it and and
whether and what the appropriate
entities to apply for it is really does
beg for a rigorous process in this
committee to answer the questions around
this funding source and whether or not
we have the appropriate enabling
statutory language to to uh ensure that
this this money does come to the state
of New Hampshire from my mind there
there's a number of ways that this
committee could go if if we were to
engage in in a real robust robust
process and answer those questions if
the money could be housed within a state
agency the department of energy or
another state agency
there could be there could be a a new
entity created within something like the
department of the treasury which I know
some other states have done for their
Green Banks or there might Simply Be
enabling language necessary for some of
the state's non-profits to be able to uh
to go after the these funds
independently
um I think uh based on the timeline that
I have seen so a federal request for
information was issued in November uh
the that RFI closed in December and I as
I was sitting here I was reminding
myself that uh that that the the uh the
guidance the um the recommendations from
the efab which I forgetting what that
acronym stands for but it's the federal
entity that was that is providing
guidance to the EPA on how to administer
this money was supposed to come out in
December and I looked it up and and
there's a 700 page list of
recommendations that that came out just
two weeks ago so all this is to say this
is still quite fresh and I think that if
this committee is serious about making
sure that we're that we're getting back
all the federal funding that we can uh
that we we really ought to dig deep on
this issue and ask what we can do to
make sure we get those funds
you said you had two points did you make
them both uh uh I think I think that was
it yes so so it's a lot of money uh and
it's quite complicated and we and we
really ought to investigate how to how
to best go after that money got it
representative Doug Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question I'm just curious
um since your agency might have uh
already applied for some funds that it's
not open yet
um we we answered a request for
information okay a simple question are
you aware if any of these any of the
funds that might be available to anyone
could they be used for say um affecting
policies
uh so I believe that the answer to that
is no uh so the re the reason that we
responded is because another substantial
portion of clean energy New Hampshire's
operations is we provide technical
assistance to municipalities
um so we employ what are called circuit
Riders who do grant writing for towns in
order to pursue competitive grants so
that they can you know reduce their for
instance White Mountain Regional High
School we helped write a grant for White
Mountain Regional High School that
helped to get a hundred thousand dollar
USDA Grant to swap out their lights for
for LEDs and that's that's part of what
we do and that's that's what uh that's
what we would we would look to expand
additional questions representative munz
has a question thank you Mr chair and
thank you for coming in so if I
understood your your testimony correctly
um
the way that this bill is structured
where it creates a revolving fund within
the department of energy may not be may
not necessarily be the best or right way
to go about taking advantage of this
money is that correct that's right
um and in order to know for sure we may
actually need to wait a little bit until
the federal guidance document comes out
as you heard Josh Elliott allude to the
the actual guidance document as to how
these funds will be spent has not been
created yet we just have a very long set
of recommendations that will ultimately
result in that guidance document
follow-up follow-up
so that would suggest I think
retaining the bill to enable us to look
at it over the course of the summer as
things evolve uh that that might be one
way to go I would you know I I don't
know if you're looking for my suggestion
about how how to to go from here but if
I would say if I were in your shoes I I
would want to bring a number of entities
that that know more about this program
before the committee perhaps before a
subcommittee which I know has been done
in the past
um because it may be that the timeline
is tight enough that if you were to
retain the bill over the summer you may
miss an opportunity if the if the
funding were to become available over
the summer
representative Kaplan has a question
his question's already been answered
precedentive View
um
seeing no further questions I want to
thank you for coming to talk to us today
and giving the clean energy
perspective on this bill
so with regard to the question that
representative muns just brought up
about retaining the bill I will make
note of the fact that this is one of our
five early bills
so if we're going to
make a decision to retain the bill
well whatever decision we make it it's
going to be done on Friday of this week
because we're doing all the early bills
on Friday of this week so we have to
decide as a committee whether we want to
retain it or
just pass it and see what happens after
that
um
representative munz thank you Mr chair
for clarifying that I just wanted to be
clear that I was I was not necessarily
recommending that I was just speculating
well we have three minutes before the
end of the public hearing and what we
don't typically talks among amongst
ourselves about bills during a public
hearing
I would be interested to know with a
show of hands if people were interested
in retaining this bill
or
passing judgment on it yay or nay one
way or the other on Friday
well no I'm not voting I have a question
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question yes thank you when you say
retain does that include a committee a
subcommittee yes we form subcommittees
when we retain bills yes
representative Harrington has a question
yeah as I said I think this uh some
questions that we need to have answered
before we can act on this legislation I
mean maybe it's routine that they have
funding for Staffing when they give you
money but maybe it's not and since we
don't know the answer to that question I
certainly couldn't vote for a bill that
may require us to spend extra State
money and don't know how much or how
little or whatever right now this is
pretty wide open the money's there but
no one seems I mean we've heard ranges
from you know one million to tens and
tens of millions so I think until we get
more information it just would be it
wouldn't be prudent for us to pass this
on to somebody else so you'd be in favor
of retaining this yes it would
representative Munns
I I think you know given the uncertainty
I mean I I would be inclined to say
let's retain it but the one thing that
did concern me was what uh Mr Evans
Brown said right at the end which is
that there could potentially be you know
rules put in place that say that in
order to get this money you have to act
by
July 1st and then we wouldn't be in a
situation where we could do that if we
didn't have the right legislative the
right legislation in place
that is correct so the procedural issue
involved in retaining the bill is that
if we did so we couldn't discuss it
until the fall according to House Rules
we could pass it in the fall and then it
would go to the Full House in January of
next year
it might get passed by the house then go
to the Senate
no telling how long it would take the
Senate to finish it so it's probably
going to be next spring Before the bill
could go into effect if we retain it
so given that reality let me see a show
of hands of people who would be in favor
today
and this is non-binding but who would be
in favor today of retaining the bill
a question first from representative
Doug Thomas uh yes thank you Mr chairman
So based on what you said then
um
even if
the house was to approve this bill it
would still need to go before the Senate
with their approval and then likely a
committee of conference
and then go before the governor for
Signature that might not happen until
perhaps I'm guessing May
somewhere in the time period so that so
even if we acted now that's the time
that's best case it's probably May
I'm assuming with everything else going
on I just I'm I'm asking if that's a
reasonable expectation if we act now
and pass this bill out of committee
it'll go to the house floor
if it passes on the house floor it'll go
to a second committee the finance
committee where they will then ask
questions about it and they will either
recommend passage or
itl then it'll come back to the house
floor
if we pass it again then it'll go to the
Senate so the earliest that the governor
could probably see it would be
sometime in May maybe June
however if we retain the bill it'll be
the following year in May or June before
the governor sees it
so given that reality let's see a show
of hands of people who might be in favor
of retaining the bill and this is a
non-binding straw poll
I guess another question yes yeah is
there any possibility that some of the
issues that were raised today someone
could get back to us before Friday on
and say you know doing further research
on I mean especially the funding issue
there I mean I don't know how much
guideline is out now maybe if they
haven't been written uh how can we vote
on a bill for guidelines that or
requirements that we don't know I just
don't see how we can go forward with it
saying well we'll just kick the ball
over to finance and let them fix it
later which is basically what we're
doing uh and you know is there a
possibility that someone has this
information from the federal government
that they can come back here in in a
couple of days and answer some of these
questions Mr Elliott
hate to put you on the spot but do you
think you could answer that question
it's my understanding that until the
federal government issues guidelines on
how to implement these programs they
don't release the money is that true
that is correct usually once they
release something depending on the the
agency it's usually it's it's guidance
or uh administrative document basically
laying out how you do the actual
application then there's an application
period that can take a couple of months
before the the deadline I can take a
look in the documents that exist as to
whether or not uh entities that apply
for these funds can use a portion of
them to pay for staff again I would I
would be surprised if they don't given
that every other Federal program that
for example that the department of
energy runs allows for administrative
expenses to be taken out of whatever the
award is so I can but I can I will take
a look and I think at the documents that
do exist and I can have an answer before
before I believe Friday Mr chairman
that's Friday afternoon at four o'clock
yes I could I should be able to have an
answer to the committee before then
representative McWilliams
um I just wanted to put a declare that I
would be happy to meet with Mr Elliott
Mr representative Harrington
um and put together some kind of an
amendment to address some of these minor
tweaks before Friday so we could have
something possibly possible
okay sounds good
all right I think we're done here yeah
we certainly done time wise as far as
the clock is concerned so I'm going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
630 and ask representative closure to
give us the blue sheet determination on
this bill
uh thank you chair
I'll spill six
three zero
FN
blue sheet
in favor was five against zero
online 70 was in favor 2 against
okay
thank you
all right it is now
or two minutes past four o'clock so I am
going to open an executive session on
House Bill
418--fn relative to eliminating the
rebates distributed by the Energy
Efficiency fund and I'm going to recess
this executive session until Friday
afternoon at 4 pm
sorry Mr chair could you clarify
um what's happening representative
McWilliams you have a question yes I'm
sorry could you clarify I was a little
bit distracted we're we're not having an
exact session that is correct
the exact session has been uh recessed
until four o'clock Friday afternoon
February 3rd is there a reason
uh yes that's the call of the chair
thank you
okay
so now I'd like to open a
exact session on House Bill 576 FNA
local establishing an energy
conservation program and an energy
conservation project fund and
establishing the state Pace Reserve Fund
in discussions with representative
McWilliams
it has been brought to my attention that
there are potentially two competing
amendments
that what might be adopted for this bill
apparently we can't adopt both we would
have to adopt one or the other
so
I'm going to ask representative
McWilliams who is intimately familiar
with both amendments to describe the two
amendments to us so that we can then
decide if we want to take up one or the
other
motion well
I'll ask representative McWilliams to
make a motion to
um pass the Bill adopt the bill as OTP
uh Mr chair I move for the adoption of
the bill ought to pass and offer
Amendment uh this is the first one it's
2023-0162h which is very similar to the
amendment that was passed out at the
time that the bill was heard by this
committee
um
some very minor tweaks but this should
look familiar to folks who read the
amendment at the time of the um initial
hearing and I'll I'll just give everyone
a chance because we're passing this out
and it's it's a stapled Amendment it's
got a total of two pages
plus an amended analysis on the third
page
it looks like this and I'll ask for a
second on the amendment on the motion
representative munz will second the
motion
so we have
one Amendment before us
which is amendment number 2023-0162h
which replaces the original bill with
the language of the amendment
thank you Mr chair can I speak to my
emotion
you may speak to the motion however what
I'm confused about is that the Second
Amendment
if we were to pass the First Amendment
and then take up the second second
amendment the Second Amendment would
completely rep replace the first
amendment is that correct that is
correct Mr chair I think we would only
take up the Second Amendment if the
First Amendment failed
so we'll take up the First Amendment
first and then the Second Amendment
okay
the floor is yours
thank you Mr chair um
so you should all have a copy of the
amendment number zero one six two H it's
three pages it's stapled in the corner
um as you probably recall from our
presentation on the pace bill this is
implemented in 22 States it's a private
Funding Solution this amendment that
we're looking at here changes the name
of the program on line 11 of the first
page
it is c hyphen Pace to make it super
clear that this is a commercial Pace
Amendment and it does not impact
Municipal pace which is already on
Statute in the state of New Hampshire
the intent here is that
um
borrowers who choose to use commercial
Pace funding can access a 30 federal tax
credit
with the infrastructure reduction act
they could get up to a 50 or 60 percent
tax credit so for a large developer
doing something like large housing in
New Hampshire either say a mill building
conversion or new Greenfield ground up
construction of a new housing complex
this is an excellent way to access the
funds we did talk about the funding
mechanism being a lien against the
property and being collected the same
way that the property taxes are
collected through the municipality that
hasn't changed we're simply clarifying
that this is commercial Pace five units
plus commercial building it's very
similar to a tiff or an oz District
um sort of like revitalization and
historic credits all of these programs
are intended to apply
for a developer who would like to access
5 funds but needs to pay them back even
if they sell the project so the lien
runs with the property
um
also there are some strings attached to
the underlying cpace fund I just want to
be super clear
if you're doing this project you do have
to improve up to 40 percent of the
building efficiency for a renovation
project and for new construction there's
a baseline that you need to increase by
40 efficiency in order to access the
funds so the change between this
amendment that you're seeing here and
the amendment that you saw when the bill
was initially presented is that on the
very last page of the amendment we're
looking at page two
lines 12 and 13.
it says that um
the lien is going to have the same lean
priority and status as other property
tax and special assessment liens as
provided in RSA 80 which is the enabling
statute so what we're doing here is
making this a more interesting
investment of the vehicle more appealing
to someone who wants to do private
Equity loans by making it have the same
lean priority meaning that if a property
is going bankrupt and the town ends up
taking ownership or a separate mortgage
takes ownership at the same time that
the property taxes need to be paid off
to the municipality this loan also needs
to be paid off in order for the property
to change hands so it creates a more
enticing investment so a lot of the
concerns that we heard during testimony
have been stricken completely from the
bill this is really meant to be enabling
so that we can do commercial Pace in New
Hampshire so that private Equity Funds
can come here and do loans to developers
and gosh fingers crossed we can get some
more housing in New Hampshire I'm happy
to answer questions thank you
anybody have any questions about this
amendment representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair
um can you just um
you mentioned the number of states that
already have a program like this can you
can you just give me that number again
please there are 22 states with enabling
c-pace legislation on the boards thank
you
representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative just to clarify the the
bill as we first saw it was more than
enabling legislation it also has some
Provisions for setting up the financing
mechanism and this bill does not have
that just as an enabling legislation
pieces am I correct in saying that you
are correct all of that Administration
has been completely removed this is only
enabling it's up to private Equity to
decide how to actually do the financing
thank you
representative Harrington has a question
it's so clear the existing 576 is gone
that is being replaced entirely by uh
230162h yes representative everything
else is disappeared in the trash all
right thank you
seeing no additional questions is there
any discussion on this bill
representative Summers
thank you Mr chairman just my discussion
just look at the amendment the hardest
part I have with this is that basically
the entire Edition on page two
and forgive me I know where science
technology energy but just reading it
everything in the every single one of
these lines except for line six has to
do with Municipal and county in my
opinion it has to do with penalties
property taxes town city districts it
has the only thing that has anything to
do at all with science and technology is
line six where it's Energy Efficiency
and clean energy District everything
else what I can see has to do with
Municipal and County committee so I
don't even know I don't believe it's in
the right even the right committee this
is my opinion thanks
just as a point of information because
of the letters appended to the end of
the bill number
fn-a-local it will be going
to the finance committee potentially to
the Ways and Means Committee potentially
and to the municipal and County
government committee potentially
it'll be up to the speaker to decide
what committees that it actually goes to
so
before we take a vote on this uh
Amendment and this legislation I just
want to welcome representative Carrie
Speer to the committee who's sitting in
today for representative
Reynolds and also to representative
Allison nutting Wong who is sitting in
today for representative Kat McGee
and we already have introduced ourselves
to representative Jack who is sitting in
for
representative cretieren that's correct
so
with that in place we can now uh if
there's no further discussion of this
legislation we can vote on the amendment
2023-0162h I would ask the clerk to call
the roll
on the adoption of the amendment
Doug Thomas
yes
Janine nodder no
Michael Harrington
no
Troy Marner no
no Lex brezhny
no
JD Bernardi yay
Tom blochet
uh it's
let's see Rebecca McWilliams yes
James Summers no
so you're not on the list I have to add
you by hand
um
Marty Jack yes
lucious partial
yes
Tony Kaplan
Christmas
yes
and we know
Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman
yes
Gary Speer
Allison nothing wrong yes
chairman Vose
yes
fifteen one two three four fifteen
years four Nays the motion carries
so the motion to adopt
Amendment
2023-160162 H is adopted by about a
fifteen to four
now ask the clerk to call the roll on
the adoption of the
will as amended no
that's right uh we're actually going to
consider a second amendment
oh okay so there is no Second Amendment
to consider that's good news
um now I would ask for a motion on the
on the bill as amended representative
McWilliams
hang on
we've got a counting problem over here
apparently
oh representative you were a no yeah
and murder was a no he didn't have his
mic on but he said no
Harrington was no correct that's
fourteen to five okay
okay so the corrected vote was 14 to 5
to adopt the amendment
Now record representative McWilliams
would you make a motion to
uh adopt the bill as amended
representative muns
second it's been moved and seconded that
we adopt HB 576 as amended by
amendment
2023-0162h is there any further
discussion
seeing Nana asked the clerk to call the
roll on the question of
the adoption of HB 576 as amended by
Amendment 0162h
Doug Thomas
yes
Janine nodder no
Michael Harrington no
Troy merner no
Lex brezhny no
JD Bernardi yes
Tom plagee yes
James Summers no
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Marty Jack yes
lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns yes
Henry Noel
yes
Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes
Carrie Speer
yes
Alpha nothing wrong yes chairman Vose
total is the same fourteen to five
so by a vote of 14 to 5 house bill 576.
has uh as amended by zero one six two H
is adopted
and that will close the executive
session
on House Bill 576.
so I will now open an executive session
on House Bill 92 and I will recess this
executive session until Friday at 4 pm
Friday February 3rd at 4 pm
and with that we conclude our business
for today I thank you all for being here
and I'll look forward to seeing you all
bright and early nine o'clock tomorrow
morning where we'll be hearing I believe
six bills during the course of the day
tomorrow
have a pleasant evening and a safe ride
home thank you